uh just an FYI they we're going to be a
few minutes late our Chairman's taking
care of business upstairs and scheduling
and so forth and we've got a number of
people stuck in traffic so we'll get
can
thank you Mr chairman uh members of the
committee good morning um my name is
representative cam Kenny I represent uh
straford County District 10 which
includes Durham and the University of
New Hampshire um today I'm here to
introduce hb1
1670 uh so this adds the total amount of
state aid for special education services
to Grants uh made for adequate education
so I will uh Begin by briefly just
walking you through the bill um and
explaining why I introduced
it so on page one lines four and five it
adds language to the educational tax
rate set by the commissioner of the
Department of Revenue to include an
additional amount equaling the costs
needed for a truly adequate education
for uh special education services online
lines 9 through 12 on the same page it
states that the revenue from this
additional amount uh for the cost of
special education services shall be
deposited in the education uh trust fund
on page one lines 18 through 20 it adds
language to make it clear what uh equal
education opportunities means and that
providing an appropriate public
education that also regard special
education services as part of the
state's duty to provide a constitu
constitutionally adequate education uh
page one line 23 through page two lines
23 shifts a burden to the state through
the education trust fund to provide the
cost of all services for a child who has
an IEP ensuring that they receive a fair
public education the State Board of
Education would adopt the rules for
school districts applying for and
identifying special education costs page
two lines 26 through 32 as well as 33
through 36 again updates language to
specify that children who qualify for
special education services are
considered and included in the state
policy that all students are provided
with the opportunity to acquire an
adequate education that will prepare
them for life at after school um lastly
page three lines 1 through 18 amends the
current mechanism for including special
education costs and the adequate
education amount lines 13 through 14
deletes the current funding of 2,100 and
ads language to ensure that special
education costs are added to the total
uh under page three lines 8 through 12
um so I think everything else in the
bill kind of speaks for itself I'm
admittedly not an expert on this so I'm
open to uh the wisdom of the committee
to any changes they see fit that matches
uh the intent of this bill um it's it's
really the first time I've put in
education bills um I I grew up in an IEP
granted it was in Massachusetts I think
because I had um an IEP it set me up for
Success I'm in law school now I'm a rep
um and you know I'm pretty passionate
about making sure that we um Ure special
education costs um are adequately funded
um not being an expert there are people
lined up after me uh who may be better
fit at answering some of your questions
um but I'm happy to take any that you
you thank you Mr chair good morning
representative um I'm just questioning
um the intent is it are you looking to
to add the cost of special ed to be the
same as base adequacy the 4100 is that
what that means well it it shifts it
from local to state to make sure that
it's funded adequately across um New
Hampshire regardless what that okay
regardless what that amount is uh yes
okay
the know we have special ucation a SE
fromy
though
[Music]
respons so three and a half times so the
district has to pop up the $70,000 first
then between the three and a half and
the 10 times that cost State ks in 80%
cost Beyond 10 times that average the
state pays
that that's their with along with that
80% so looking at have you done any
calculations far
stuc um to be honest no um there is a
fiscal note that we're waiting for how
the how this bill would impact um I
haven't all I can say to that is I I
have heard from constituents um in my
district and others that don't believe
currently um special education is
adequately funded um and I believe this
this proc process would um fund it more
fairly and ensure that we uphold our
constitutional
constitutionally
um testing oh we could now um to make
sure that every student including those
um getting a special education um um
gets an adequate education so I have one
followup to that how then will we there
are districts that may not have a
student that qualifies for special
education
Aid they don't have maybe a cat Aid or
why then are they going to be
accountable in the base adequacy for
those costs or or why are we going to
fund them for those cars when they don't
have anybody they may have a student
that is IEP are you talking about if
there's an IEP of any kind from dollar
one you're trying to shift into adequacy
is that what you're trying to
do essentially um you know I
I to the people who help me write the
bill um they may be better at answering
that question um I I see we have some
people from Dr and doe here so maybe
those technical things can be asked for
them yes sir thank you the questions
representative
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for bringing this bill forward um I'm
specifically looking at the line um EMB
bolded that says the provision of a free
public educa or free appropriate public
education under this chapter shall be
considered a part of the state's duty to
provide every child with a
constitutional or constitutionally
adequate
education um now I'm sure being both a
rep and law student you're aware I'm
sure others are aware for those not
aware um obviously everything we have we
have to do here has to be in keeping
with the Constitution um but there's a
difference between a bill and a
constitutional amendment so I'm asking
given this line clearly is adding
something to the Constitution a
constitutional requirement how can this
be done as a simple Bill and not a
constitutional
amendment um so my understanding would
be that currently the Constitution um
ensures that
we the lawmakers will provide every
student with an adequate education I
think that this bill just ensures that
the mechanism that we use to do so um
upholds the intent of that
constitutional
mandate if I may just a quick followup
on that because you're you're correct on
the the concept but would that language
not say then according to the New
Hampshire Constitution we shall do this
not adding this provision to the
Constitutional
requirement um perhaps I I to be honest
I don't think a cacr was necessary for
the intent of what we were trying to do
with this bill um but like I said um not
in expert um so I would uh you know so
long as it fits the intent of the bill
um you know could use the wisdom of the
committee you're welcome thank you are
there further questions represent
cordelli uh thank you Mr chairman thank
you representative for bringing this
forward
um the um discussion about the amount of
the cost of special education services
um are you
talking uh right now the state
contribute some um via uh the uh formula
uh that we have for funding plus the
district's um uh fund at special
education as well are you talking both
state and federal dollars
to be included
in um to be honest if it's okay I I'll
wait until someone else to answer that
PA yes um I'm just wondering about lines
five and six on the first page where it
seems um as though you're adding the
cost of special education services to
swept the Statewide education property
tax so it seems to me that you'd be
asking the local districts to raise that
363,000 I wish 3 363 million um plus the
cost of special education so I I think
you with this language you're actually
asking the local districts to raise a
substantial increase in the Statewide
property
tax is that is that your intent
um so I don't know if if you'll be
satisfied with this answer um my intent
was to make sure that special education
um costs are adequately funded so I
worked with experts who are a lot
smarter than I am on writing bills uh
like this who know more than I do who
believe that this language would be the
best uh Way Forward um and they will be
testifying and probably could offer a
better answer further further questions
from the
committee uh representa are you familiar
we have another bill before us that's
being that's been put in by the
representative from
Manchester uh to establish a commission
to look at this issue which is one we've
been looking at for
decades um and we recognize the
importance of it but there's a lot of
strings attached to it and a lot of
technical aspects you know there's a
component within differentiated Aid also
how we do this
so um are you aware of that that she has
put this amendment in to really take a a
a ster look at this um to be honest I
didn't know that um but it's good that
we're continuing to have the discussion
here further comments from the questions
thank you very much thank you Mr
Shen
good morning uh my name is Zach shien
I'm the executive director of the New
Hampshire school funding fairness
project I appreciate the opportunity to
1670 um I've been trying to take some
notes to to answer some of the questions
hopefully that have been brought up so
far um so for uh my understanding of the
intent of this bill which is to shift
the burden the the financial
responsibility from local property
taxpayers to the state for paying for um
special education
services um so during the 2021 2022
school year um just under 30,000
students
29715 uh which is 19% of our total
student population receive special
education services special education
costs accounted for about $843 million
during that same school year about 25%
of the total New Hampshire education
expenditures however and these are some
of the questions that were asked earlier
the state only covered about $61 million
through special education adequacy
grants so the differentiated Aid side of
the
formula with an additional 32 million
distributed um for what was previously
been known as catastrophic Aid that
three and a half or 10 times the amount
of the average
expenditures uh federal aid and Medica
Aid combined provided about $64 million
so all told the vast majority of funding
is currently being covered by local
um because we have heavy Reliance on
local property taxes who fund not only
special education services but also the
um the vast majority of the rest of our
public education system uh these
property tax rates as mentioned earlier
vary pretty widely um from District to
District depending on their equalized
value per people the amount of value
they have the ability to tax to raise
that funding um so having the roughly
650 million
that local property taxpayers currently
fund currently rais to pay for special
education services which are as noted
critical services for students who need
need them to succeed at the same level
as their peers um we currently pay for
about $650 million of those Services
because the state provides so little so
my understanding of the intent of this
bill um is to shift that burden for all
special education C Services all special
education costs from local property
taxpayers to the state uh the mechanism
that it uses in this bill is as noted um
directly tied to swept so there would be
a increase in swept which is a property
tax and then a decrease because the
state would now be picking up $650
million more of the funding that we
currently spend so I'm sure doe or
others could show town by town the
impact of that where if your tax rate
goes up to to provide the swept but then
you now get all the your special
education services covered some towns
might see a a higher spending some towns
might see lower you know Winchester for
example had 40 40 something per of their
budget with special education services I
imagine they would see a significant
decrease in the local property tax rates
because they would have more of the
services
covered relative to um the other funding
bills that the committee has heard um
and I hope that this bill will be
included in the subcommittee studying
special education funding there's some
different ways of approaching this here
but I just want to end and I'm be happy
answering questions but I just want to
end by pointing out
that it's important to keep studying
this issue but I don't think that anyone
can defend the current levels of
spending right now um I think it's
important to decide and understand what
steps we can take as we continue
understanding the nuances of the very
complex issue that is special education
funding and services um but I don't
think that the amount that the state
currently spends um again about 61
million 93 if you include that
catastrophic Aid category compared to
the total $842 million that we spend on
special education services that a very
small amount coming from the state
requiring significant burden on local
property taxpayers um so appreciate um
being able to offer this testimony and
happy to answer any questions at the
best of my ability are there any
questions from the
committee
ref can you just repeat those last two
numbers that you just said the state
contribution and the total cost yep so
this is for 2021 2022 the total amount
of expenditures for special education
funding was just under 843
million the state in the differentiated
Aid part of the formula contributed 61
million
and then if you include the special
education Aid that three and a half or
10 times the amount that's an additional
million thank you very much you're
welcome further questions okay the thank
you very much Zach thank you um the next
to that I'm going to call up here first
I'm going to call Mark Mago neelo uh
from the doe who is in charge the
finance side here and then following
Mark I'm going to have Dr come up and
million Mark is coming up neither for or
against he's coming up as technical
support to
us hello everyone Mark
manganello Bureau of school finance
department of education apologize that
this bill does not have a fiscal note it
was originally assigned to our sped
Bureau but sped Bureau um said to me
because it does have some adequacy
components um um so I'm going to I have
this a memo here with the fiscal
analysis but I'll go through the normal
Channel and try to get a fiscal note on
this bill um um as soon as I as as soon
as I get to that so a couple questions I
heard I just want to explain um there's
a lot going on with sped in the way this
bill changes sped as proposed um
so uh there's a sped aid program it was
formerly known as catastrophic Aid
several years ago um it's just called
sped Aid that is the $33 million grant
that representative lad was talking
about where we pay for high cost fed
students that's $33 million it's a state
funed program um then there's fed
differential Aid which is part of the
adequacy formula so that is not sped Aid
it's sped differential Aid and some
sometimes the naming of things can be a
little bit uh
challenging um and that is the
$2,100 for each sped student um so it's
a different uh uh different funding
vehicle
um so this is really changing sped Aid
it's making a new sped aid program from
the $33 million program to a different a
new program a program that's closer to
um $869
million um but it does a couple things
does interact with adequacy in a couple
different ways so it
actually um when we talk about adequacy
in the Constitution the Constitution
says cherish education case law La has
said that means you need to provide an
adequate education case law also says
you need to provide an adequate
education Define it and fund it um so
this is reang the definition of what an
adequate education via state law which
is something the state does the state
defines adequacy via state law and then
um describes it funds it Etc um so this
is adding special education into um into
adequacy so that's sort of the the the
flow from adequacy as a a constitutional
concept into state law um so essentially
What's Happening Here is there's a new
sped a program the new sped aid program
will be 95% of all sped cost as I read
it um so uh sped cost in fiscal year 23
were 915
million um as I already printed this out
and on my walk over here I realized um
there is some double counting in there
not a lot um probably some double
counting of around um at least 12
million maybe a little bit more I have
to do more analysis but it would be a
dozen or so million in double counting
um in that number um uh basically two
leas reporting the same cost was that's
what I mean by double counting um so
that number is just a tad bit high but
it's pretty close to the approximate uh
cost of of what this would would be um
so 95% of that is 869 million so that
869 million would be raised through the
swept so it would be currently the swept
is 3 63 million so 8869 million would be
added on top of that and that is a state
education property tax that would be
raised in Revenue so the state would see
an increase in Revenue through the swept
from the expenditure sides um this bill
as proposed um eliminates sped
differential Aid which the net cost of
the state is around 27 million um and
that's a little bit unique in a sense
it's because we have this hold harmless
if you get rid of sped that's a whole
other conversation um but right now it
costs 27 million to get rid of uh sped
aid for fiscal year
25 um it also gets rid of the existing
sped aid program which is 30 around $34
million um so that budget appropriation
would go away um it would be funded not
by ETF dollars but by the well by the
swept um essentially um so the net the
new sped aid program would be 869
million so essentially
um uh what this would do for the locals
is is um 88 million in spend funding
would come from um a state Source um the
local Source um basically it's shifting
from a local local property tax to a
state property tax so that shift would
be about um uh negative 869 million and
so the net change is actually um 61 net
Statewide the net cost would be impact
on the locals would be ne61 million and
the reason why it's negative is because
we're eliminating the existing sped aid
program and eliminating differential Aid
and basically the rest of it's just
shifting from a local property tax to a
state property
tax so that's mechanically what's
happening here um uh I have a couple a
couple of technical considerations to
think about uh with this bill um it
doesn't really address federal revenue
federal revenue is not described in this
system um so potentially you could have
the State taking responsibility for
something the fed's already claimed
responsibility for so more work would
need to be done to uh delineate those
two those two funding
revenues um there could be a lag in the
swept um what we can raise in the swept
and what we actually have to pay uh the
swept needs to be set in advance of tax
bills um so there could be a lag in what
we raise in swept where it doesn't raise
enough Revenue to fully cover this grant
um and then um currently the sped Bureau
um this is not my SP Bureau is not my
program um they currently oversee SP a
program which serves 700 students um
this program would be serving 30,000
students so they would likely need um
increased Staffing to to provide
oversight over this new
program so lot to take in um I'm open to
any
questions representative
cascaden thank you Mr chair and thank
you Mark for taking my questions um I
understand these numbers but the federal
government has never delivered the
full cost of a special ed program or at
least the percentage towards a special
ed to the states do you know what the
current uh federal rate is in
percentages and then do you know how
much the state in a percentages funding
versus a
local I don't want to put you on the
spot but I'm trying to think of
percentages to break it out because
those are three funding sources I don't
have my calculator in front of me but
Zach provided a lot of those numbers um
uh that were correct so Federal funding
idea Grant is 50 million is um so that's
Federal funding and like you said
Federal funding does not cover that 900
million right um uh State funding is the
swept oh sorry as the um sped aid grant
which is 33 million um then there's
differential Aid um which is typically
you know ballpark around the 60 $60
million uh $60
million um so yeah the percentage if you
however you tally up those percentages
the local share is a lot it true that
it's about
19% of the of the
budget uh 19% of total expenditure is
correct yeah thank you
yeah further questions you have any
followups that to uh represent cascaden
you
good okay represent
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for the technical sport is very helpful
um as is this analysis um assuming the
numbers are roughly correct it seems
like the total tax increase is 689
million so pushing upwards s billion
dollars a very big increase but then the
next line uh bolded line State
expenditure total says of that only 88
million is expanded on sped so is this
is this suggesting that over $60 million
or roughly eight something percent of
the bill 8 point something is actually
not having anything to do with special
education the bill
only um no the bill stays within the the
framework of sped
um I'm not sure if I follow the question
uh if I may just to clarify so what I'm
suggesting is it looks like the state is
taking in more than $60 million in
excess of what it would actually cost to
fund the sped program which means
there's more than $60 million that are
going to go somewhere here the education
trust fund but that's not sped related
it doesn't go towards SP yeah let me
explain that um so the state is going to
raise 869 million through the swept and
the state is going to spend on sped 869
million but there's a save a um but
they've also now the state has
eliminated sped Aid so the state has now
got a savings of $33 million that that
money goes that money just sits in the
education trust fund this bill does not
spend it would
eliminate it it's finding a new funding
source right now any spare dollar that's
not a swept dollar would be going
towards the sped aid program but this
program redefines it to be funded
through swept so it basically cuts that
program because it's redefining it so
that money would be just sort of out
there it it' be in the education trust
fund so there's a cost savings to the
state by eliminating the existing sped
aid program and building a new sped aid
program and then there's a cost savings
to the state uh by getting getting rid
of the sped differential Aid so I'm just
trying to since it this program
eliminates existing sped funding
vehicles and creates a new one there is
some cost savings there um but the total
sped
spend uh is going to be 869 million so
what would be increasing SP
spend just if I may real quick because I
I I follow what you just said but I
don't follow how that relates to where
it says here State expenditure total 800
8,
32226 compared to the revenue intake of
$869
m459
1865 so you're saying that that that $61
is million difference is not uh that
that is going to be expended um in sped
sorry no it's it's
um it yeah I guess maybe it's maybe this
isn't a maybe my table could be a little
bit more um it's looking at it's it's
it's it's trying to it's a little
confusing because it's trying to say we
are going to spend 869 million in sped
but we're not going to be spending
spending these existing programs so
there is a State Savings for those other
programs
um it's yeah it's a little complicated
it's just netting the
total the bottom line to your state
budget um that $60 million you could
take that $60 million because it's
sitting in the education trust fund and
reapply it to the sped to bring you back
up to the 869 million but it's just it
it' be do this is more for this is more
useful for finance committee because
they would see those dollars sitting
there thank you I got a question that
related to all this um approximately
what of the
residential uh uh students which we have
that're placed outside the resident
District uh those which are uh homebound
those that are in hospital settings it's
approximately somewhere correct me if
I'm wrong around 700 kids
approximately um we don't know when a
student like that's going to show up at
the particular districts they oftentimes
move around and that's part of the
problem the district is coming how do I
cough up this huge amount of money now
with it coming in the way it is proposed
to come into is there going to have to
be a separate fund within each School
District to ensure that that the money
that is needed when that student shows
up that it's going to be available to
pay off the yeah Services yeah there's a
cash flow issue that districts have and
most districts uh well I don't know
about most districts um substantial
amount of districts build a sped trust
fund to deal with that exact cash flow
issue so they keep money in their bank
so they can afford to pay those bills as
they come in um and uh they have a a
sort of something some appropriation
Authority they can tap into um so it
would districts would like likely still
want to manage for those cash flow
challenges if they come up um they would
be ultimately under this bill they would
be reimburse by 95% so the funding would
come in um but you're right there could
be a a a there could be a lag as far as
when the bills are due and when the
money comes in that that's where I'm
coming from and with the fact that we
have some small districts I have one in
my district that has 67 kids in it um
receed two residential Place kids in one
year they don't have a trust fund so
they have to look at elsewhere within
their budget to find those dollars take
it from Peter to PayPal or they have to
take some kind of a tax anticipation Noe
out so
um recognizing these districts small
districts do not have that fund set up
they just have don't have the ability to
do that financially there's going to
have to be some place where that money
is a available for those districts to
pay for these costs of that very very
expensive residential placement which
they are on the hook for
now I don't I don't know how this is
going to do that um without the state
having that money and reimbursing
whether it's been totally the you know
the state's done all which they're
responsible for I recognized that when I
came on board here there were 210,000
kids in the state and we had 30,000 kids
which are IEP eligible approximately we
have 160 some odd thousand right now and
there 30,000 the IEP so there's special
head is you know per capita is is
increasing I I think um cash flow and
distribution of the funding I don't know
this bill basically wants the sped
Bureau to redesign its rules and so I
don't know how much flexibility in law
they would have to be more aggressive
with their distributions to mitigate
cash flow challenges I don't know how
administratively efficient it would be
to be cutting a lot of checks or how to
do how to how to uh uh establish a
distribution schedule that would would
alleviate that challenge um I can't
speak to that and I don't know if the
bill um fully sort of thinks about that
concept it leaves it to Ru making
essentially thank you represent Tanner
then represent cordelli and then repres
just to make sure that what we're what
this bill does is it puts all the burden
or the majority of the burden for
special education back on local property
taxes is that is that probably the
result it it puts it all on property
taxes um but it would be the swept so
it' be a state property tax not a local
property tax but but still on my bill
it's going to be a property tax property
tax thank you refson
Celli uh thank you uh just following up
on that so the Local District would have
to collect the additional $800 million
from the local taxpayers that would then
get sent to the state to be deposited in
the education trust
fund and then there would be um through
state aid the bottom of page one um
there would be some offset sent back to
the locals to try and balance out or um
reduce uh property taxes because of more
specialed money coming in from the state
is that correct that's that's
mechanically what's happening okay
follow up yes um I'm just questioning
then um uh State a is on the bottom of
page one uh but then in Roman 3 on page
two it talks about rules related to
school districts applying for special ed
under the new state aid
program um I'm not
sure um I'm not asking you about the
intent of the bill but um it seems to me
that the district would have to apply to
the state to get that funding from state
aid according to what I'm reading
correct yeah and and swept would have to
be raised in advance of that so that's a
there's a mechanical challenge there or
a lag in when what we predict this the
districts will apply for and we will
grant and what the swept will raise and
so
um you know I don't know what the
methodology would be um it could be one
year raise one year and then see what
happens next year um it would likely be
short because sped costs typically Rise
um that's but that's mechanically a
challenge with this bill represent
leus yes with swap the way we do it now
um not all towns can raise the amount
that is set for their sweat and the
state then covers that
difference from the educ ation trust
fund and the question is would what
would happen with this CU now we're
asking even more money to be raised in
swept would those towns that can't raise
that much
money have it covered as well in uh with
the represent because I think you're
talking about adequacy so so this is not
adequacy um so every every Community um
has a tax collector and that tax
collector collects um uh this is just
how local uni vers school districts
taxes work um the tax collector goes out
and um everyone gets a tax bill the tax
collector goes out and everyone sends
their tax bill in um in theory they're
supposed to pay 100% of it um and 100%
of that um in theory what would should
be raised goes to the school district if
you're talking about communities not
receiving their full swept amount that's
an issue between the mun and if they
want to put a lean on that property but
that's a separate issue okay so always
all the swep money has to be collected
correct and have to be paid to the
school district than and that's what we
what I would imagine would happen here
okay thank you are there any more
questions yes represent Bel thank you Mr
chair and thank you for this um I have
an idea in my head about a incentive
structure that this could create so just
a very simple question as of right now
the way this works when a child has to
get an IEP um the approval process for
that that all occurs at the local level
correct um I believe so I'm not a SP SP
bu's behind me but yeah local thank
you representative
dry uh thank you and thank you for
coming
um we talked about the number of
students then the doe would be
responsible for when from 700 to
33,000 is that uh 30 30 around just
under 31,000 um just under 31,000 would
be the type of um uh students eligible
to for the schools to seek reimbursement
for okay follow
um any idea how much the staff might
have to increase to accommodate that
it's not my program but I don't have a
number okay thank
you any further questions thank you very
much
up let's talk
swep
once again Dr is here not taking a
position it's more technical support for
us that is correct uh good morning good
morning chairperson and the members of
the committee my name is Keen mayong tax
policy council with the
Dr my name is Bruce can I'm the
supervisor of the municipal Bureau at
Dr um so uh we did prepare a fiscal note
um oh yeah yeah yeah as just wanted to
repeat what uh representative L was
saying that yeah the Dr does not take a
position on this bill uh we did prepare
a fiscal note uh we were requested to
prepare a fiscal note by the LBA um at
the time when we prepared the fiscal
note we I guess the uh the knowledge on
the uh special Aid special education Aid
uh was was not as uh um as complete for
us at that time uh when we prepared it
we put it at $33 million uh we use a $33
million budget budgeted special
education Aid as the the amount of money
to be raised to be added to the swep but
hearing from the testimony from Mark is
$869
million um and so our um our
understanding is that that $869 million
will be added to the $363 million that
would be collected through swept um and
then that 869 million will be remitted
to the Dr and uh transmitt it to the
treasury and then to the
ETF um
the the only potential concerns that the
well some of the potential concerns that
the Dr has is in terms of uh the timing
of things um of um potentially if if
that $869 million is that the final
number that um that Dr would be adding
to the swep uh calculation um if not
then we would need to know um what the
final number and and the timing of
knowing that number so that we can add
that to um to our um when we issue the
the swep warrant um as well as the
timing of when the
um a more specific timing of of when the
um the municipalities will be remitting
the collected um special education uh
funding to the Dr to be uh transferred
treasury yeah yeah
further are there questions from the
committee here regarding this
process I think we're all trying to
filter through
this not seeing you thank you very much
thank you
y and the last card I have on this is
tremble
good morning again Mr chairman how are
you today fine thank you good oh I have
some
testimony so I had some prepared
comments but before I get to them I just
wanted to kind of take a step back and
look at the comments that were already
made three things come to mind first is
that that the Constitutional issue and
adequacy Claremont says it applies to
all children so this statute says that
special ed students would need to also
get an adequate education I think that's
redundant it's not necessary to be in
this law because we already have a
constitutional duty to provide that to
special ed students the second thing was
the question of what's the percentages
breakdown and this came up last week in
the hearing it's 82% local right now 11%
State and 7% Federal so out of all sped
dollars in New Hampshire the state only
pays 11% that's broken down in the two
categories the differentiated a which
goes out with the adequacy grants is
about seven or 8% and the categorical
Aid is about 4% so we're paying 11% now
this bill would have us pay as a state
95% so just to compare last week's bill
with this week's Bill last week said
let's take the differentiated Aid which
we give about 2 or 3,000 per child who
has special ed needs and increased that
to 28,000 per child so it said let's
take that part of our state funding
mechanism and put a massive amount of
money in so that special that is no
longer a burden on the the local
government the state would be doing its
responsibility under Claremont there
this bill takes the other half of our
state spending not half the other
portion of our state funding categorical
Aid and says let's just put all the
money through categorical Aid basically
just have a revamped massive categorical
aid program that we're going to pay $95
% no matter what it costs whether it's
three and a half times or 10 times your
normal student expenditure so but the
point is if you commit to Let's fund
special education you can do it the way
you proposed last week just massively
increase the differentiated Aid or you
could do it the way this week let's run
it through categorical aid but the
question is will you commit to massively
increasing the state's funding for
special education how you choose to go
about doing it which Bill obviously
there's a lot of technicalities which
need to be worked on this legislation
could use a bit of work in committee but
I think the first question is are you
willing to commit to the state funding
special and and if so which approach do
you prefer do you want to go through a
differentiated Aid massive increase or
do you want to go through a categorical
AIDS increase which would be this week
so that's and then as far as the federal
government it's supposed to pay 40% they
said they would do that in 1972 and
we've been waiting for them to do it
they're a deadbeat parent they're not
going to ever do it it's time that we
just step up to the plate do it because
these are our children these are New
Hampshire children so I want to add two
other things um to the to the agenda
here first is that special ed students
only receive about 70 or 75% of the
services that they're eligible to
receive in other words there are unmet
special aid
needs that's true nationally and at New
Hampshire there was a study um done
nationally found that in public schools
and Charter Schools nationally this has
receive about 65 to 75% of the necessary
funds to cover special Ed programs that
was a study done by Claremont Graduate
University in New Hampshire um I found a
report uh in and it was in the UNR
review which cited the New Hampshire
School Board Association now this is
going back to 2015 but special ed
fundings only being funded to
approximately 70 to 75% of eligible
entitlements so we're not funding
special LED fully so if we could make a
commitment to it then I think unmet
needs would be able to be met because
local governments just are unable to
meet the entire need the last question
is well is it worth it and besides the
fact it's our moral duty and our legal
Duty it actually produces benefits
special Ood funding re produces
education gains which produces saving
the state money in the long run and you
say how could you know that if you don't
have a control group it just happened
that Texas decided to say only 8 and a
half% of students could be special
students this was in 2006 they just came
up with this number and said that's all
we're going to permit you to do they did
that for 10 years years the federal
government sued them and said you can't
do that that's not rational it got
overturned but what it did was it
created a whole fund of information for
social scientists to go back and study
and look at it you had you had your
perfect control group you could compare
what happens to kids who had special ed
and those who lost it and what they did
so the economists went to work on this
and this is from the American Economic
Journal in
2021 even the students who had minor
disabilities had significant increases
in their High School completion rates
but for students who had more
significant disabilities and firm
disadvantaged districts the likelihood
of completing high school if they lost
special ed went down by 52% and the
likelihood of going to college went down
38% and they say this is because of the
services that they received the variety
and strength of services that they
received and they say conclusion our
results suggest there are large
meaningful long run returns to investing
in special ed services in the public K
through2 School setting for students on
the mark charge and placement especially
those from disadvantaged background so
in other words special funding works we
know funding Works in general but it's
also true of special ed funding so it's
something to keep in try so go back to
the beginning it's our legal obligation
it's our moral obligation it makes sense
economically now the only question is
are you willing as a state to say we're
going to do it and then to decide do you
want to do it through differentiated Aid
or you want to do it for categorical Aid
either pass last week's bill or pass
this week's bill but one of these bills
should be
passed are there question questions for
Mr
Trumble yes representative D dry thank
you and thank you for coming in want to
ask you a philosophical question kind of
um there is a resolution right now to
ask the uh our federal delegation to
look into fully funding the special ed
things but in the meantime we're
following all the requirements but only
getting less than half the the
reimbursement that we're entitled to is
it moral kind for us to to disregard
their uh requirements because sometimes
those are honorous and expensive and
maybe not necessary um because they're
not fulfilling their side of the
contract why do we have to jump through
the Hoops that we do to get that money
because of the children I mean it it's
they have a right under federal law we
have a constitutional that requirement
that every child should get an adequate
education it's our responsibility and
the federal government has not lived up
to its share of the deal for 50 years
and waiting for them to finally show up
is ridiculous they're not they're not
going to come or even if they do come
then we can go back and re re whichever
one of these bills you passed you could
go back and say yay the federal
government finally spent some money and
then reduce the state share but waiting
for them is not a good policy let's
let's fund it now if they do eventually
come up with more money then we can
reduce the cost through either of the
bills but sitting and doing nothing
because they might show up again
somewhere in the next 50 years I think
that that would be unfair to the
children just follow up yes yeah I
wasn't suggesting we not do anything I
was saying do you are you are you saying
we continue with um as if they were
refunding us completely and getting just
accepting that it's less than half of
what we are we're entitled to yeah I I
think we have to continue to to fund
special ed and I think the the people
who work in special ed know that every
day when the question was asked how did
the IEPs come up the child comes into
the district the principal and the
special ed directors say and say okay we
have a new child what are their
disabilities who are the experts
involved in this field let's sit down
and come up with a plan by law they have
so many so many days to come up with the
plan or they're out of compliance and
then they they do it and so we have to
continue doing that I I don't think
there's any other realistic Choice okay
thank you does that answer yeah I think
so okay thank you representative dry are
there any further questions from the
committee not seeing thank you very much
oh thank you Mr chairman and not having
any other cards that bill I'm going to
close
time okay the next bill which we have in
it so going ahead
1678 uh there may be some on the on the
table back
there um I I have one right here I I
might have printed my own too
but who does on the who in the committee
1678 yeah Mel's going to get I was going
to have Mel bring
more need uh why don't you bring about
two extras just you just leave you like
handing a card you can hand it out at
the end excuse me excuse me I just want
did my Phil Brown get put in a little
pile of
P
welcome oh thank you okay great thank
you okay we're going to go ahead and uh
start accepting testimony on 1678 and
the representative that's sponsoring
Simpson
table thank
you uh for the the public if you see
folks getting up and going elsewhere
it's not that they're trying to do
something they they have to get to
another hearing and they're a prime
sponsor elsewhere in the building so
they probably are going off to test ify
or co-sponsoring a bill so welcome
representative
Simpson thank you Mr chairman Good To Be
With You honorable members of the
education
committee thank you for hearing 1678
this morning establishing a New
Hampshire Farm to school local food
incentive pilot program this bill
represents many years of dedicated time
and energy from stakeholders across the
state those in the Agriculture and food
sector those in school nutrition
programs and those community members who
are part of the social infrastructure
that makes the local food economy Thrive
last year we submitted a bill requesting
State investment in a farm to school
program that school districts across the
state would be able to access after
feedback from this committee and
conversations with the Department of
Agriculture we have come back this year
to ask first for the development of a
pilot program to help assess the
feasibility of a local food incentive
program
before attempting a program that would
allow access to all schools school
districts
Statewide New Hampshire's Farm to school
program already operates in some schools
across the state local food nourishes
children supports local farmers and
strengthens the resiliency of our supply
chain in many
communities however there are currently
schools across the state who would like
to get involved with the farm to school
program who need encouragement fiscally
and operationally the pirate pilot
program program would allow one school
district in each of our 10 counties to
participate schools across the state can
apply to the Department of Agriculture
who will put together a committee and
criteria to choose schools to
participate in the pilot program the
department will also gather data from
the pilot program in order to discern if
and how to best go about a farm to
school incentive program that would be
accessible to all schools across the
state last week the United States
Secretary of Agriculture Tom vilsack
spoke here in New Hampshire he described
the many ways that we can support
farming and Rural communities in New
Hampshire one of the one of the ways we
can do this is by investing in our local
and Regional Food Systems investment in
the farm to school programs is an
investment in our economy investing in
our local and Regional Food Systems
especially our rural economy makes a big
difference in the economic viability of
our small and medium-sized Farms
especially not only can we help our
rural economy but we can also improve
the health and well-being of our
children and the resiliency of our local
food system a robust Farm to school
program will help strengthen New
Hampshire's agricultural sector and
security that's all I have to say but I
I figure you may have some questions so
I'm happy to take any of those questions
and and then also happy to tell you that
many of the folks who contributed to
working on this bill and who would be a
part of the um pilot program itself
administering the pilot program itself
are here and they are happy to take your
technical questions as well thank you
are there questions from the
committee yes representative Damon thank
you Mr chair and thank you
representative Simpson and team for
bringing this bill forward I'm
vigorously supportive um I wondered if
you could comment on what other states
are doing in this
regard yes um I can say generally and
then if you have real specific
information um the director for the farm
to school program is here and can tell
you more um but we are lucky to have a
graduate of tough's uh graduate school
who did a a nationwide study of all
states and what they are doing in the in
farm to school programs in their state
and so we were able to talk with her a
lot over the last um uh couple few years
really to see what works and and what
doesn't she really analyzed all the data
and was able to share with us here are
the things that are working here are the
things that would be a challenge for
your state to try to help us have um the
tools that we need to you know even with
a pilot program we want it to be as
smooth a roll out as possible um so our
neighbors in Vermont and Maine um have
robust programs that we've spoken to
their um Administration their directors
as well thank you yeah further questions
from the committee yes representative
Pell thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question how many schools
across the state have requested this
program I'm afraid that's a technical
question I'm not able to answer I I
would think that um Stacy Perlo who
directs the program would have more
information on that thank
you yes represent Boney thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question um on the expenditures that I
see the
um the
$120,000 is that uh to be applied uh for
the uh reimbursements
alone yes I believe in the fiscal note
it says that
um the bill appropriates yeah exactly um
I think also it will be helpful for you
to we have um uh a representative from
the Department of Agriculture market and
Foods here who will speak to that as
well um because they are already working
on a particular Cooperative agreement
around Farm to school so thank you yeah
further questions from the committee
represent beler represent Miler after
represent Belcher thank you Mr chair and
thank you for bringing this bill forward
um I really don't dislike the underlying
concept I like the idea of supporting
local farms I have a couple of questions
um about the particulars in this um
because this is all new money being
expended toward this pilot program it's
um I don't believe that's going to be
reimbursable so why is it that we would
exclude any school not participating in
the free lunch program the USDA program
as well as require USDA mandates be
followed instead of setting up our own
and taking this at the state
level so I'm going to let Stacy purlo
take that question who works with um the
USDA closely she will have more
information about how the um the
programs
interact if I may just one similar but
not quite the same I mean just looking
at the nutritional items in here and
what is included and what's excluded can
you tell me why it would specifically
include maple syrup which is I don't
know if it's particularly healthy and
it's quite expensive but it excludes
milk um sure so we've had a lot of
convers ations over the years about
these things I'm going to do my best and
then allow um others to fill in um any
gaps in knowledge but I believe with the
school breakfast program there are often
foods that um have syrup involved with
them and we would um prefer that they
use um and buy a syrup that we produce
here in New Hampshire and support our
maple syrup farming industry and not um
uh
ship non- maple syrup from other places
across the country um so that's the
maple syrup uh question and then um uh
fluid milk so we found through the
research that we did with the help from
the and I'm sorry I can't remember her
name right now um the uh a tough student
but we were able to look at what other
St have done and one of the challenges
theyve found is that if you include
fluid milk in the reimbursement program
then that um completely consumes the the
reimbursement program because you have
fluid milk at every um every meal I
believe and so in order to try to reach
the goals of the program which is to
support um the food system broadly and
to increase our resiliency in our food
security
we are already purchasing um a lot a lot
of places already purchasing um fluid
milk but it would be important to also
include these other um range of
vegetables and fruits and ciders and
meats and fish um to build that
whole local and Regional food
web thank you are there further
questions represent Miler uh thank you
Mr chair and thank you for being here
bringing this before us did I hear you
did I hear correctly say that there
currently are some programs in school
districts
already yes absolutely thank you for the
question representative Miler there are
um a number of schools across the state
who are doing um Farm to school
purchasing um including I live in exer
and we um ourselves have been doing Farm
to school purchasing
since um my oldest is in his first year
in college and when he went into to
kindergarten I volunteered to broker the
first sale of carrots to our local
school district with a farmer that I
knew who had extra carrots and so how
many years is that we've been doing it
in exiter for 13 14 something like that
years so a followup please yes so how
does this how does this program work I I
mean you obviously the carrot is one
example but what's the dynamic around
how this whole program would work sure
so the carrot is a very basic example
very early on in a program um and it
really schools School nutrition
directors are able
to um do the program however works best
for them so different depending on where
you live across the state there might be
different local foods that are available
more easily to you like on the Sea Coast
you might have more fish available or um
I know our food service director drives
from her region is able to pick up more
apples from there um so it does vary
from place to place it also varies with
how the Food Service directors um work
with their colleagues to do um sometimes
they'll do uh programs special programs
like try it Tuesday where the food
service director will pick a vegetable
that that she knows students have never
had before for and will they'll just do
a special program where all the kids get
a little cup of that vegetable and
that's what they get to try that day um
and so it sometimes has a curricular
component or a garden component but this
this build this pilot program and the
the meat and potatoes of the farm to
school program is connecting with
farmers in your local area and having
the foods that they grow and um and
produce be available to your school um
and I know last time that um she
testified Stacy plea was able to share
with us more broadly kind of what the
farm to school program does so she might
also have more to add here follow yes uh
so the purchase of the local product are
they at market price are they at a
discount price or how does that
work I think I think it depends so I
don't really have data on
that hopefully someone behind me can
help with that is um sorry further
questions representa Pell thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question have there been any studies on
the eyesight of the students in exiter
with the carrot program I'm sorry I just
couldn't help
myself any other questions from the
committee thank you very much and you're
welcome thank thank you appreciate it uh
as we've had policy in the past in
various bills because the number of
cards put the two-minute rule in for
those the the prime sponsors always
given more latitude and the those that
are co-sponsors or others who want to
speak to it two minutes and we will have
the timers going so I'd like to have
torski thank you Mr chairman I will be I
will be within my two minutes if not
briefer um
I'm here not as an expert on the farm to
school program but simply as a believer
in the advantages of connecting farms
and small producers with our local
communities and school
districts this program would benefit our
agricultural sector benefit our school
children who may not have the ability to
access local products and local produce
as we know introducing foods to young
children builds a strong foundation for
a lifelong healthy
eating I actually represent NASA's w 8
which I neglected to mention um but in
nasua I would encourage any opportunity
to bring healthy choices to our lower
income students for many students in my
city this program could be their only
chance to partake in Local Foods and the
programming possibilities that repr
representative Simpson just outlined
could probably be their first connection
with how foods are grown
this is really a winwin win a win
because it's a pilot where we can
evaluate how it works knock out the
positives and the negatives it's a win
for our farms and small food
producers it's a win for our schools and
it's a win for our students I'll end
there but I thank all of you for your
consideration and represent
representative Simpson for her work on
this Bill thank you very much are there
any questions from the
okay uh next one is Joshua Marshall from
the New Hampshire Department of uh food
agriculture good morning uh for the
record Josh Marshall director of the
division of agricultural development for
the New Hampshire Department of
Agriculture markets and food uh I'm here
to provide some information um on behalf
of the department we're not taking a
position on the bill but um some
information on our ability to administer
it and our experience with a very
similar bill um through the F through
USDA um we currently administer the
local food for school Cooperative
agreement which is federally funded we
received
$58,900 agreements uh for
$188,400 180 with several more in the
pipeline expect to have about
$250,000 in funding going directly to
schools for something very similar to
this where their requirements are to
purchase local and Regional minimally
processed
food um so I'm very confident in our
capacity to administer the program
within the funding level that's in the
bill and with a smaller number of
schools with a maximum of 10 schools in
this bill we have up to 40 that could
have participated through the uh
federally funded
program um yeah I think a couple other
things that I noticed um line 24 and 25
of page one mentioning the ability to
purchase kitchen equipment specifically
for use in processing cooking and
storing and serving local food would
make it very easy for the schools to
expend what they would get if 10 schools
get funding it would be a little over
$10,000 per school and that would be
pretty easy if they only purchased
equipment um but there's also a a bounty
of local products available in the
region for them to purchase their um
over a little over
$10,000 uh would not be a hard
lift um some of the issues that oh
that's
it we're right at the end of that if you
have a few more all I just going to say
some of the issues we faced with
administering the program right now why
I think there's a a a lower turnout in
participation is the capacity uh for
Food Service directors uh to do the
paperwork and the reporting um Staffing
changes we've seen folks that we had
reached out to a staffing change and the
paperwork got lost in the mail and uh
the original program allotted money
based on a formula this would be an RFP
process so those who would be most
interested in participating would have
um the ability to do so thank you very
much all are there any questions from
representative
dry thank you Mr chairman thank you for
coming to testify um can we talk about
border towns and how you determine
what's a New Hampshire product and
what's not you know the cooperatives in
our area in the Upper Valley consider
local as within 100 miles so um looking
at the the reimbursement rate can you
discuss that at all yeah so uh the the
New Hampshire the state definition of of
local is within the borders of New
Hampshire there's no there's no um
outside the border the USDA definition
is a radius from the point of production
um so uh sorry from the point of sale so
in the program that we're administrating
uh through USDA we have to use the USDA
definition which is 400 miles from the
point of purchase and so those border
towns count as local and Regional food
um if if we were to use the New
Hampshire definition for specifically
this bill it would only be products that
were raised in New
Hampshire
yes there's still kind of some gray
areas is what's produced by New
Hampshire people in Vermont or processed
in Vermont and sold in New Hampshire and
I'm just wondering if this addresses any
of
those I I'm not sure all all I'm aware
of is that the definition of local in
State Statute is only produced within
the borders of New
Hampshire I'm going to follow up with
where represent R is because I'm also
from the Upper Valley we have a probably
one of the largest milk producers in our
town hatchin Dairy but we also have
school districts that are Interstate
school districts which their districts
extend over to Fairley Vermont they up
on on the North side to Canan down to
Brattleboro uh all over where we're
we're sending kids back and forth so uh
up our way local is local and it means
the other side of the river too and so
we raised this in the last time this
bill our bills like this came forward
and there's real concern that we respect
um when we are putting things out
through our select board municipal
government uh we also see local as any
town that AB buts our town on our side
and so it can be over in Vermont as well
so something that I think we got to be
considering when we look at this and the
same thing on the other side of the
state too with
Maine absolutely and
Massachusetts I'm just reading just
reading from the bill you know it's as
it's written I know you didn't write
this bill I know you're a technical
sport so we're not hammering on you so
um are there any other questions yes
represent cordelli and then represent
pum uh thank you very much for being
here for your support uh technical
support um I just wanted to ask about
this USDA a program um did I understand
correctly that there are six schools
participating um at the cost of
$188,000 and you expect that to grow to
$250,000 correct and follow up yes um
how long has that program uh been in
existence here uh so that program
started in in September
of the agreement was made in September
of 22 through a number of technical uh
issues and and and some hurdles um its
completion date is September of 2024 of
this year so they we have the rest of
this school year and a portion of uh
September to expend the rest of the
funding and those lessons that we
learned that I mentioned I think would
be uh mitigated now that we've gone
program um could we get an indication of
what uh schools are currently
participating I I could get you a list
yeah great thank
you further questions represent perel
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um I spoke with a
local farmer um in preparation for this
bill and he told me that when they were
trying to set up double up food bucks
and the um a Granite State Market match
the part of a snap program that the
costs to the farmer were so exorbitant
they would have had to hire another
employee on their Farm just to keep up
with the record keeping would there be
recordkeeping associated with this on
the farmer side I mean it's really
expensive to farm and to make a money
make earn an income as a farmer without
government
subsidies thank you for the question uh
there W from as I read this there would
be no requirement on the farmer um both
the local food for school program and
the local food purchases assistance
program another USDA uh funding source
we have um that we're administering both
are designed to have the least onus on
the Farmer they would be their products
would be purchased through normal uh the
normal ways that anybody else would if
they participate with a distributor then
they'd be available there if the food
service director or their staff can go
directly to the farm then they can do
that but uh they might not even know
that they're participating in the
program that's
for further questions thank you very
persol good morning so I'm Stacy perso
with the New Hampshire Farm to school
program I work out of the University of
New Hampshire in the sustainability
office so why does local food matter uh
growing producing and buying local food
represents opportunities to build
resources wealth and resilience in local
communities and to Balance power more
evenly across the supply chain um eating
Local Foods has become a priority of the
United States Department of Agriculture
to strengthen roal economies address
environmental health food access and
nutrition along with agricultural
producers and markets Across America
Transportation distances land use crop
yields Animal Welfare we are budgeting
for 8 to 10%
increases a significant amount of this
increase seems to be due to
Transportation costs with increased fuel
prices and availability of commercial
truck drivers some of the many
advantages of purchasing local products
is to lower these Transportation costs
lower emissions and improve the quality
of the products the government County
Office says that food food prices are
going to continue to grow and are
predicted to increase at around 8% this
year by addressing supply chain
disruptions the federal government May
indirectly take action to address Rising
food prices so one way and Josh
mentioned this is with the local food
for schools Cooperative agreement
program each state was
awarded
wow I only got through a paragraph can
you just uh you know give a summary of
what you've got there without having to
read it sure uh so we also have the
granite state farmed plate RSA 425 2A
which which encourages state agencies
and the government to support um local
producers um do schools already buy
Local Foods I know we have some schools
that have been buying local foods for a
long time other schools don't
participate at all so this incentive
program is meant to encourage other
schools who may not be participating to
to start doing so um schools are buying
you know storage crops apples carrots
potatoes winter squashes proteins ground
beef eggs fish um value added Dairy like
yogurt uh lenis and spinach with our
Hydroponics and Greenhouse production is
available is written in your it is yeah
can you provide the clerk a copy of what
you have here yes I have copy all so
there was another question um what is
the impact of these programs across let
somebody else ask the question okay well
somebody asked it before goes the other
way here okay okay representative
peternell thank you Mr chair thank you
for being here and taking my question
can you tell me let's see if I'm wording
this correctly what is the ability of
the farms in the state of New Hampshire
to feed our current state population
like what percentage of the population
could be fed imagine New Hampshire is an
island what percentage of the farms in
New Hampshire could feed our total
population did I say that right what
percentage of the population could be
fed by the farmers in our well so that
that when that statistic is out there
it's not quite worded that way it's it's
it says that um our state buys 6% of our
food
locally and and um the rest of our food
we get from other
places further questions from the
me yeah just can can you thank you can
you explain that statistic a little more
6% of the food that we consume in our
state food you consume might come from
New Hampshire
producers
so thank you repr
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for your testimony um I believe I heard
that the USDA is trying to
prioritize local um funding of food um
and then from what we know it's not
coming back again so
um so I don't know that the USDA is
going to say that schools have to buy
local they're trying to you know
encourage it but they still have um
guidelines in place about how a school
has to go about purchasing food um they
have to put food out for bid um if they
only have you know a couple of dollars
put a meal on a plate it's still um as
far as I know they're not going to be
giving more money to increase the amount
of money they get to produce a school
meal so there's a lot of obstacles that
can make it difficult for a school to BU
local so we're trying to make it
easier thank you represent dry thank you
and thank you for coming uh with all
these programs we've heard about today
and I'm looking at now vital communities
over in my area that's already doing
Farm to school projects all the time
that are funded do we have enough
collectively already that we've done a
2-year pilot program in New
Hampshire um we don't have like data
around that collected around that I know
and when I say when a school says they
participate in farm to school it doesn't
always mean they're buying local food
because there are other components of
farm the school like school garden
programs and classroom education so they
could be doing that or maybe if they buy
apples once from a Orchard they they say
they're doing Farm to school so I don't
really have good data to support your
question can I have a follow yes thank
you um what are some of the impacts of
the program you were just about to talk
about oh so um so as representative
Simpson me me uh mentioned uh there's a
grad student at tus who did her master's
uh program on Research around these
reimbursement or incentive programs that
are in about 15 states across the
country so the impact um these programs
can support small new and
underrepresented producers they support
more direct Farm purchases which gives
more money to the Farmer they support
socially geographically and economically
diverse student populations there's an
increased demand for Local Foods New
locally produced food products have been
developed just for schools they improve
local food supply chains they increase
opportunities for nutrition and
agriculture education they increase
participation in school meals and that
the economic impact is greater than the
investment represent beler thank you Mr
chair sorry but this just jumped out at
me as another question um so we we just
heard that the the USDA uh guidelines
that are imposed by the federal
government for the free lunch program
make it difficult to really expend those
funds locally um however uh article six
in this bill says that all food
purchased through this program shall
comply with the national school lunch
program guidelines so would this bill
not be hampered in that exact same way
as current programs it's it's those are
the nutrition guidelines so it has to
meet nutrition
guidelines that that's also here but it
also says all national school lunch
program guidelines must be adhered to
right right as far as how they have to
go about purchasing food
yes further questions from the
representative Tanner thank you and
thank you for taking my question I
wonder if did the study point out that
it's probably more important for as
representative tersi mentioned living in
nashwa that the urban areas be exposed
to this whereas I think in the Upper
Valley and um in suvin County which
representative dry and I represent uh
I'm sure most of the kids in schools
there um have gone apple picking or have
been exposed to
farming yes so um I know there's been
some Farm to school efforts in the nsha
school district and there's a number of
garden programs and a number of the
schools um the same in Manchester uh the
food service director there um has made
some efforts to purchase Local Foods um
and I think and if I don't Josh can
correct me but I think Manchester is
going to be on board for the Cooperative
agreement funds um so they are going to
have I don't know
$100,000 to spend on local and regional
foods um
soon further questions from the
committee thank you very
of which you were the chairman of that's
correct good morning thank you to uh
chairman lad and to the house education
committee I um what I hope is a
beautiful narrative story about the
importance of local food for our
communities and I'll share that um uh as
I can I have a few copies here I think
what I'd like to bring to this
conversation that I haven't heard
represented yet today is the concept of
agricultural and food literacy which is
so important for all of us um so beyond
bringing local food into our schools we
all know that it's important how we feed
children how we talk about the food that
we feed them and um how they see us
going about sourcing and buying our food
uh and it is no different to need to do
those kinds of things and talk about why
you're eating what you're eating and how
you are bringing food to the table at
home than it is in school and so by
investing in our youngest New Hampshire
citizens and saying we do want schools
to bring in more local food and we want
this to be a bigger conversation so that
these young New Hampshire citizens can
uh grow up understanding more if they
live in an urban area where food comes
from and how local food is an important
part of their their lives in their
community so we're shaping habits in
purchasing we're shaping habits in
eating and we all know I'm sure Brody
from New Hampshire hunger Solutions can
um provide some statistics on a lot of
kids are receiving the the majority of
their calories at in a school setting so
it's it's critical that they have every
opportunity to be um meaningfully
engaging with our local surroundings um
with local and Regional food in the
school setting um it's not really a
luxury it's something that as we look
towards our our climate future and our
children's
future it's critical that they shape
these skills at these De Young
developmental stages you know we all
think about baby and how important it is
for them to start feeding themselves and
getting those fine motor skills but as
they grow older with each age bracket
come different critical food and
agricultural literacy skills and
bringing these Foods into the schools
and having them talked about and
celebrated in schools will help children
develop those um those Frameworks thank
you very much I'm happy to take any
questions are there any questions from
the
committee not seeing you thank you very
much thank you uh Phil
Brown
good morning my name is Phil Brown and
I'm a retired conet High School science
teacher and we're sitting under the
portrait of my colleague who in 11 days
from now would have been dead now for 38
years okay Christa mlli the last two
lines on her Epitaph on her headstone
written by her husband she loved her
spaceship earth she taught her children
to do the
same to me the most important aspect of
this bill as a retired teacher is the
potential that it presents to as this
young woman from Hanover Co-op just said
get our children involved in farming and
agriculture the most important skill set
that we can pass on to our children
right now in an era of food
insecurity is how to grow monitor
Harvest process store and eat healthy
food what this bill will do will be
allow children through their teachers to
interact with community members Farm
farmers who are doing just that and that
to me is the critical piece of this
legislation is that
interaction and that's all I need to say
thank you very much are there any
questions from the
committee thank you folks thank you for
yeah like to invite Heidi Baker
Extension thank you I'm Heidi Barker and
I hail from Coos County working for UNH
extension Cooperative Extension I'm an
extension field specialist for health
and well-being today I'd really like to
speak to the robust extens the farm to
school network that we've been building
in the Andre gagen Valley up in Coos
County I've been working with my partner
Stacy Perlo to do this since 2018 and
I'd like to share some of the real
reasons why this bill this particular
bill would this and this network could
work hand inand based on what we've been
doing with schools in the past couple of
years the schools that I work with along
with Stacy and several Community
Partners include th two of our school
districts sa3 and
sa20 and includes Berlin Elementary
Berlin Middle High School AOL
Consolidated School milin Village School
gorm Ed Fen Elementary School and their
middle high school in addition we also
work with Berlin Headstart which
includes some of our most vulnerable
students or population in our
County so I serve as a co-lead and I
also have expertise around food access
and food and security for Cooperative
Extension but what's really important
here is that we had a couple of Grants
to support bringing in our schools and
helping to them to
build action plans around School
procurement they're ready to do this
type of work we also have a and
nutrition education action plans and
they're very excited and very engaged in
this work already in these schools that
I've just
mentioned a couple of examples um and
how we're actually creating data as that
built built into our recent
implementation grant that we just
submitted to USDA includes contacting of
44 Farms this past year in our local
area to discuss establishing a farm to
cafeteria relationship and that includes
14 of them actually getting back to us
saying yes we want to work with you we
want to work with our school Food
Services this also involved discussions
with okay all right I did I did want to
mention one thing if I could um what
happens when it doesn't work because we
do have schools that are the first this
this fall they brought in fresh corn
from my from one of our mland farmers
and they also have m maple syrup that
they've been using since we've been
working with them but when it doesn't
work we have Berlin third grade
classroom and this this teacher is an
amazing rock star and what's happened
with her is that she's doing our New
Hampshire Harvest of the month education
but she's not able to actually bring in
the local foods with the taste testing
and that comes through the opportunity
to work with the school Food Service I
will note Berlin Elementary School is
one of our high EST free and reduced
lunch figures in the state as well as in
our County at 62.3 2% this is where
these things can work together thank you
Nikki Heidi Heidi thank you and I called
you Baker in his spker it's okay you
know it's but thank you so much I
appreciate my time you're welcome are
there any qu questions for the co-op or
the extension service uh yes represent
leus great right here oh right there oh
I'm sorry I was looking over here sorry
I certainly believe that um local fresh
food is better for you than um traveled
across the country and potentially from
Mexico or even farther you know because
food deteriorates over time but I
am trying to work out the um I guess
actual costs of the
program to subtract off
what does it cost the St what does it
cost on average do you know to buy say
carrots the way other schools are buying
carrots from wherever versus what the
carrots would cost this way just so we
can see what that difference is so
that's a great question it's something
that I don't have at my fingertips but
we would certainly want to research that
and get back to you I can say just based
on the work that I do in Coos County and
some of of the events we've had Local
Foods is definitely more expensive we
have to understand that a lot of hard
work energy goes in with those producers
I I I understand I'm just trying to get
so I can't give you that percentage but
I'm sure that's something that we can um
figure out and get back to the committee
thank you good question thank you
further questions representative Pell
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um my children were
raised on a farm I have a daughter who's
a chef and
she has participated in some of these
farm totable programs learning how to
cook from Farm to Table obviously but
the disconnect even at the
professionally trained Chef level of
where your food comes from and what it
takes to raise that food and to get it
to the table there's still a surprising
disconnect at
that level of Education how are these
children actually learning where their
food comes from Because unless you've
actually been
working in the dirt right on a daytoday
basis it still just shows up on your
table and there's this it just magically
appears right you you come and sit down
for lunch and there's your food what is
this process of bringing the farm to
these actual students so that they
really experience it sure so that's an
another great question and I appreciate
that representative so there's lots of
ways that we do that with our farm to
School programming in the in the six
schools as well as Berlin Head Start
that I mentioned we have been able to
put hydroponic units into our schools
with some of the grant money that we've
received we're doing try days and we
also are doing um opportunities for
field trips and getting kids out onto
the farm so they can see what's going on
the other thing about UNH Cooperative
Extension is that we do this uh
collaboration again with Stacy and her
programming New Hampshire Harvest of the
month as well as pick a better snack so
we talk about these things and so we're
in the classrooms as well as training
our teachers to do the same thing so I
can speak about what's happening in
Andrew scogan Valley in particular
because these teachers as we've created
a a network of staff and teacher
Champions who are really excited about
this work and they're dedicated to it
and even without funding this year which
we don't have these teachers and staff
are doing this work and that's why we
just submitted a a bigger USDA Grant but
um it's it really is about us getting
out there and training using some of the
evidence-based curriculum and materials
that we have and working with our
teachers to share with them these ideas
that you're talking about I too was
raised on a farm and understand where
our food comes from but you're right
there is a disconnect and that's why
we've built this network it's a
system and it's baby steps that's what
I've learned from the last last 15 years
in the work I've done with health and
well-being and with food security
efforts it's that it's baby steps we're
only going to be able to do so much at a
time but we can do it thank you further
questions represent Ry thank you and
thank you for coming um I'm hearing all
lots of pieces I know the Cooperative
Extension has a real robust program
throughout the state and um you were
saying they were ready to procure up in
your area and coos
that was ready to
procure yeah that was your words so I'm
trying to as is is that just mean that
you need money to put this into
action so um when I talk about
procurement this is a partnership with
our local producers as well as with our
school food service and as part of our
action planning Grant we were able to um
really research and identify in in our
area this Andrew scogan Valley region
that includes those schools how many
farms do we have that would be working
with us and there are actually 14 that
express interest as well as what do our
food service directors need to purchase
the food to um to um prepare the food
the types of equipment that they need
and so we're able to do that with some
of the grants that we have available but
what what I'm what we're finding is that
sometimes our food service really needs
that kick in the butt if I could say
that um and this pilot project could
really help help us do that in the North
Country okay
follow so what's the kick in the butt
then is just that the program is there
or does it still need funding well I
think it is funding I mean it is trying
to buy those additional um Local Foods
because they are expensive okay thank
you represent Belcher thank you Mr chair
and thank you for your testimony uh
quick question do we have any idea
currently in terms of percentages what
amount of food served in New Hampshire
schools is sourced from New
Hampshire so if I I don't know if I can
ask Stacy to to share that but I I don't
have that answer but we can probably get
that to you great thank you are further
question represent
cascaden thank you uh and thank you um
Heidi for taking my question is there a
definition in the in the distance of
what local means because I'm referencing
the 10 acre Hydroponics of lettuce being
open in the North Country um this spring
and if somebody from Nashua wanted to
partner with North Country Growers for
the greens would that be considered
local so that's another great question
and thank you representative
cascaden what we did and we were able to
do with the last planning Grant is that
we actually were able to Define what
local means to us and and so that's
within our Network and the work that
we're doing with this Farm to school
project and our definition is
progressing to the rest of New Hampshire
and then adjacent States within 100 mile
radius so I don't know if that is in
conflict with this particular bill but
that's how we're doing trying to work
with some of the farmers that and
producers that are close to us yeah we
will be addressing local okay good good
excellent doesn't that resolve the
situation of the Upper Valley or anybody
on the borders because of the 100
mile yes there there are a number of
farms there's like four corner farm
right across the river from us right in
newbur right is a huge farm that sells
all over that's right thank you yeah so
uh are there any further questions thank
you very much all right thank you I
appreciate your time Robert
Johnson from New Hampshire Farm
Bureau thank
you looking up the definition of local
here when you find out where it is let
us
know RSA 426 col5 for for the record my
name is Rob Johnson representing Fierro
is the federation's policy director and
we are in support we this uh we see this
is an improvement over past bills that
you have seen this is the third one I
believe we particularly like that is it
is a pilot as we have suggested we we we
want to ensure that in is to many the
questions it increases current local
food and it is not simply a
reimbursement uh for what is already
happening and we believe that the pilot
will will help us get get to that point
we also like that this this version is
been administered by the Department of
Agriculture previous versions were
administered by the Department of
Education there are two specific pieces
in the bill that we would like to see
changed and I I the chair has already
indicated you'll be looking closely at
one but it maybe in a different light
than we are suggesting but on page two
line nine where there's this uh the uh
uh eligibility for reimbursements for uh
16.6% from of food from other New
England states we believe that is too
broad uh that it that it uh I we would
say we support the definition of local
with the where New Hampshire taxpayer
money should be going to purchase food
from New Hampshire Farmers your
constituents that would be that's our
and the second piece that we would uh
like to see changed is or um page one
line nine and 10 it says a selection
committee will be assembled by the by
the Department of Agriculture and and we
would hope that in in and the the
ensuing list is a suggestion to the
commissioner but we'd also like to see a
farmer or farmer repres representative
added we believe this will enhance
communication and understanding of of
the way the the the food chain works
works both ways with Farmers
understanding the program and and uh you
know the the the others understanding
the farmer end of
it thank you for your time and
attention I'll leave it at that very
timely well done well are there any
questions for the Farm Bureau do you
have a list of you know of of farms
where are are or does maybe commissioner
Jasper have that of farms which may be
very interested in participating in a
type of program like this
uh we could certainly provide a list
when something like this is is is
developed um we
could thank you I mean we have a
membership list but that's not something
we normally would would cast wide um
right but we we could provide a thank
you list yes thank you very much uh the
next
card uh is it Nikki C or is the last k o
b or
it thank you so
much welcome thank you for the
opportunity to speak my name is Nikki KB
and I am the operations director at NOA
New Hampshire and I'm representing NOA
with my
testimony the Northeast organic farming
Association of New Hampshire NOA NH is
dedicated to helping people build local
just and sustainable Food Systems by
actively promoting organic regenerative
ecologically sound farming gardening
eating and land care practices for
Healthy Communities as a member of the
New Hampshire Farm to school network in
a Statewide Association representing
Farmers gardeners and eaters in New
Hampshire we support the local food for
local schools reimbursement pilot
program this program will increase food
security and resilience in the granite
state provide Farmers with new and
increased Market opportunities Foster
relationships between farmers and
schools improve Farm viability by
infusing
$120,000 per year into the Farm and Food
economy provide New Hampshire students
with access to fresher local
nutrient-dense foods help students learn
about local and seasonal Foods through
direct experience introduce students to
careers in agriculture and Food Systems
and allow New Hampshire's public schools
to receive financial reimbursement for
$1 out of every $3 spent on food
purchased from New Hampshire Farmers
producers and Fishers and $1 out of
every $6 spent on New England grown
caught or produced
Foods over the last four years we've
seen how a largely import-based food
economy can be affected by external
conditions leading to food insecurity
the local food for local schools
reimbursement pilot program will
increase New Hampshire's food security
law contributing to meeting the New
England feeding New England goal of
producing 30% of our Region's food by
2030 if the pilot program is successful
it will also set the stage for broader
institu institutional purchasing in
future years which would help farmers in
the long run in addition to the health
benefits for Children and Families this
bill will help improve our agricultural
economy and overall economy by keeping
federal dollars in New Hampshire and
increasing business for our states
essential Farmers producers and Fishers
and um we ask you to please join farmer
students parents and Educators by
passing this Bill thank you very much
are there questions from the committee
yes rep representative pno thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
this is a very nice program and I
noticed NOA is um included on the back
do you have any idea how much this cost
to produce that lovely book this lovely
no I don't know how much it costs to
produce but I thank Stacy for producing
it further further questions from the
committee not seeing it thank you very
much thank you so much yeah Jean
Jonas or
Jones is Jay o
joh well H good morning thank you for
letting me speak today um I've been
farming in Hillsboro County for going on
15 years now I'd like to share with you
some information I just found out about
when I was doing a research project on
the true cost of food I've been putting
this together and I'll begin presenting
it actually tonight Wilton at the town
library so at 5 so you're all
invited 30 million School meals are
served each day to our children in this
country many ingredients are GMO and are
derived from crops sprayed with
glyphosate as a drying agent for those
who of you who don't know uh glyphosate
is the active ingredient in the
Roundup
uh moms across America America headed a
recent study whereby 43 school lunches
from 18 locations nationwide were tested
for glyphosate
ampa 220 pesticides 104 drugs and
hormones uh heavy
metals and mineral
content uh by the way ampa is glyphosate
breakdown and can even be more
toxic here are some of the key
findings well over
93% had detectable levels of glyphosate
weed killer 28 of the 44 School male
sampled contained wheat ingredients and
100% of the wheat products tested
positive for
glyphosate 29 different types of
pesticides were present in
74% of the school
lunches 100% of the school lunch samples
contained heavy
metals like Haren acadmy lead and
Mercury Summit over 6,000 times higher
than the epa's maximum levels allowed in
drinking water lab testing showed that
most samples were sorely
deficient oh you got to be kidding
me all right
so I believe our kids deserve better I
know the produce that we grow at our
farm is done without any persistent
synthetic
toxins I was on the early stages of it's
called the New Hampshire feeding New
Hampshire program where food pantries
around the state can get funding from
the New Hampshire food bank to pay local
producers for their products we use this
system
sell after our CSA picks up and we have
leftover produce is that a written
testimony that you could present to us
just summarize we've got that yep so can
you summarize I think there's been good
information here regarding what's been
put on the ground or in the ground and
what we're eating yes um so we may have
some questions for you on that
okay you're welcome to take questions I
have one um how do we sort this out in
terms of how do we know which local
farms are doing this or not doing this
and
H and if these standards are you know
the if the standard that you're
advocating here it may not be that of
USDA I don't know but how do we control
what's coming in locally is there some
oversight of that of you know what farm
a over here is doing and they're
eligible for participation in the
program how do we ensure that what's
been done is correctly done by law uh
certified organic farms uh certified
through the USDA uh are not allowed to
use uh any of the uh anything like
Roundup or a lot of these other um
persistent synthetic toxins
uh during production so that's one way
to tell if you're certified
organic we grow to organic standards but
we're not certified so there's a lot of
farms around the state like
us um for one reason or another they
choose not to get certified through the
USDA but we still adhere to the
standards so it it comes down to knowing
your farmer uh knowing their
operation um and trusting them I mean
that's so
you know know your farmer get go out and
ask them how they do business you know
and uh same thing could be applied in
this uh this school system you know
schools people in the schools get to
know the local producers how they how
they
grow thank you questions representative
leus and then representative
pel I know nationally there's a term
called natural that is people like your
farm that follow
the organic rules but does not um don't
get certified for a variety of reasons
like cost um do you know if that's in
place here in New Hampshire that term
and definition there is a a group um
called certified naturally grown and we
actually used to um belong to that group
and um it's kind of like a Grassroots
alternative to USDA organic it's less
expensive uh you still get
inspected uh on on a yearly basis so
it's similar to the National program but
just less paperwork
required uh by the
farmer uh less recordkeeping things like
that um it's it's very similar but just
kind of like
a a little easier
version um there are a few people in the
state still certifi through CNG that I'm
aware of but it's not wildly widely
known or um talked about up up in these
parts of the country okay thank you yep
representative P thank you Mr chair
thank you um you mentioned
wheat um and that wheat products are
ubiquitous yes we can't es I when you're
trying to mat feed a large number of
people it's almost impossible to avoid
feeding wheat to people anywhere right
so do we have any Wheat farmers in New
Hampshire I'm just curious because that
that's that's a
significant um
uh source of the glyphosphate yeah
problems right I I am not aware of any
perhaps Rob from the Farm Bureau has a
better um understanding there uh we
don't tend to grow a lot of grains in
New England we just don't have the the
acreage um but I'm sure there's somebody
um see a lot of corn
yeah further
questions thank you very much thank
theay
thank you Mr chairman and thank you to
the committee for letting me speak today
um I will definitely keep it very brief
I'll read the for the testimony I just
handed out there's some extra copies
that will be there um but if you can
make sure every rep gets one I'd
appreciate it I'm going to read the
first paragraph and the last two
paragraphs and I'll take any questions
and I might be I took some notes I might
be able to clarify by some of the uh
other questions that were previously
asked but um as my colleague mentioned
yesterday new hampsher Solutions
appreciates the opportunity to testify
in support of um any legislation that
has to do with nutrition security or
access to nutritional food and um New
Hampshire hunger Solutions is a
Statewide nonpartisan nonprofit
organization that Advocates to end food
insecurity improve Equitable access to
nutritious food and address hunger's
root causes for all New Hampshire
residents that improve that includes
improving our food system and making
sure that everyone is well educated on
how our food system works and how to
make it robust and
resilient um extensive research shows
that access to food in school is
essential uh to students having positive
health and educational outcomes uh Farm
to school increases um food access in
Schools benefits local economy and
provides new educational opportunities
for students these three things rarely
intersect when establishing one policy a
program but Farm to school helps achieve
these three things for small investment
in New Hampshire can help facilitate the
creation of new school programs around
the state that can show a proof of
concept for school districts and justify
future investments in this ripe
opportunity for communities and students
um so we'd urge you to please uh vote a
to pass and support House Bill
1678 um I'll kind of briefly if I I
probably have about a minute left I
might be able to cover some of the
questions that were asked so someone
mentioned
um curriculum integration I believe it
was representative PLL and a and a good
robust Farm to school program will
definitely integrate um Farm to school
as part of health and science curriculum
whether it's a community garden showing
students how plants germinate and grow
or if it's part of teaching students
what kind of nutrients are essential and
you know having a balanced diet those
things will be integrated from an
elementary level um hopefully all the
way up through high school but
definitely it's easier to integrate
those into elementary schools um I
believe some questions were asked about
fed guides uh the federal
guidelines for the USDA um
reimbursements and so believe it was rep
Bel asked that and um part of the reason
for setting those federal guidelines um
one we know that School meals are
healthy they help students access the
nutrition that they need and um the
majority of nutrients that many students
do receive during the school year or
during the school day um and also it
also by meeting the federal guidelines
those meals can be reimbursed if the
schools participate in the National
School breakfast and school lunch
program so that further makes so the
dollars can be stretched with that all
are there any questions representative
Pell yes thank you Mr chair thank you
for being here problem um I have a
question about your organization does
New Hampshire Hunker Solutions actually
distribute food throughout New Hampshire
no we're we're an advocacy organization
we help organize coalitions that work
with organizations that are what we'
call um direct service providers or like
food pantries or we work with the New
Hampshire food bank on a number of
initiatives but no our organization is
not a direct service
provider further questions
representative
beler thank you Mr chair thank you for
your testimony um I see some problems in
this bill but I would think I would like
to try to fix it if I can um so when we
look at the specifically I I I touched
briefly on this earlier when we look at
the uh item on number six here all food
purchase of this program shall comply
with National School lunch program and
federal Child Nutrition program
guidelines and then we also know that
because of the bidding process that is
required as a part of that program it is
El largely eliminated New Hampshire
sources of food because of the pricing
that's coming in uh would you agree that
that this particular line actually is
going to need to be modified otherwise
we're going to wind up in a conflict
between this law and federal law in
which These funds probably cannot be
expended in order to allow New Hampshire
funds to actually be expended on this um
requirement I'm trying to think um and
it's a good question um I'm not sure if
Because the bidding
requirement I'm trying toite it's the ug
the universal
um for how how the federal government
regulates how um those who receive
federal funds you know are able to uh to
do purchases I can't remember what ug
stands for but I'm not sure if the Child
Nutrition program guidelines if those
would include those bidding requirements
I could be mistaken um I can do some
more research though and get back to the
committee on that I appreciate that
thank you further questions from the
committee not seeing thank you very much
thanks and this does uh take us through
our cards so we're going to close this
hearing down HB 1678 and we're going to
take a short five minute break for the
committee to get up and stretch and
we'll go into the next bill which is is
thereafter oh good that she put that
record
and uh the prime sponsor is here a
yours again for the record Alicia leus
Hillsboro 38 Hudson and
Lichfield um first thing I want to do is
just ask a question of
the
well the people who are here um if you
can show of hands how many here have
never sent their children to private
school if you have never sent your child
to private
okay just trying to get an idea all
right um what I'd like to
do I if you'll allow me as a little bit
of History because that will support my
position on this bill and why I put this
bill
in
Constitution in the 90s and the early
2000s there was a push across the
country to try to change the way schools
were
funded and in a lot of cases there were
um courts who decided to step in and
instead of allowing that to the
legislators they decided they were going
to interpret their state
constitutions
um to
mean what they wanted it to mean which
was for the state to supply the funding
rather than however it was in our case
funding
and in our case in
Claremont some judges decided that what
our constitution meant was that the
state had to fully fund educ
education and there and
I believe and there I am not alone in
this there are a lot of people who
believe that that was a misunderstanding
and a misinterpretation of what the con
Constitution
says uh it says it shall be the duty of
the legislators and magistrates in all
future periods of this government to
cherish the interests of literature and
the sciences and all seminaries and
public schools to encourage
private and public
institutions rewards and immunities for
the promotion of Agriculture Arts
Sciences etc
etc It also says provided nevertheless
that no money raised by taxation shall
ever be granted or applied for the use
of the schools of institutions of any
religious sect or
denomination now their argument was that
cherish meant to fully
fun
however we're to cherish not just
literature and the Sciences but all
seminaries and public
schools the definition of a
seminary a School of Theology
Theological Seminary or Divinity School
is an educational institute for
educating students in scripture and
theology generally to prepare them for
ordination to serve as clergy in
academics or mostly in Christian
Ministry and I would ask how can
cherish mean fully fund when the first
thing we're to cherish is
seminaries now you might argue that well
this Blain amendment was put in in
1877 and our constitution was adopted in
1784 and
therefore they just overlooked that
there was a conflict but I would say if
that was the case if it was understood
that cherish meant fully
fund and seminaries was one of the all
seminaries was one of the first things
in there to be cherished and they put in
that Amendment saying that any religious
sector denomination could not be funded
then why was nothing written
about either moving
seminaries removing seminaries from
cherish
or um making that clear but nobody ever
wrote that I mean I would be glad if one
of you could come up with me arguments
made at that time to say why we were
supported why we were fully funding
seminaries uh
representative I'm continuing
that is the point that is the point to
this bill and I'm giving you the
background or why why I think this bill
constitutional
um so therefore I do not believe and
there are many in the state who do not
believe and there were many legislators
at the time of that ruling that did not
believe that cherish meant fully fund
which is why it took so long and so much
force and so many different rulings and
court cases to try to force the
legislature to come up with that because
they did not believe that was what
cherish meant and by basic logic the it
does not it does not seem to mean
that but that does not mean that the
legislature can't decide okay so we on
our own decide that we want to fully
fund education because that's how we
education but we've seen over and over
that when the state pays for things
we're not supposed to differ not
um thank you
discriminate was the word it wouldn't
come um and we talked already about
special needs and how we couldn't
discriminate against special needs
children well I would say that by only
funding certain schools and not other
schools we are in fact discriminating
against students who can't learn a
certain way students who go to a the
their zip code school and that is not
set up in the way that they are able to
learn and therefore they need to go to
maybe even just a different zip code
school but maybe to a private school or
whatever they need in order for them to
learn and so we are
discriminating by having zip code
schools the
efas were originally set up before it
kids to allow kids to get that education
funded by the state the same money that
goes to every other kid in the state was
to go so that they could get their
education based on what would work for
them which includes their Public School
other Public Schools um Charter Schools
private schools home schools colleges
you know whatever it took they would get
their education and that is what is
constitutionally
fair if the legislature decides that
they are going to pay for education for
students in the state it should go to
make sure and educate every student in
the state not just those that live in
this ZIP code or that zip code we've had
lots of conversations about how it
shouldn't pertain to zip codes about
that's why we want to fund this town or
that town differently because it
shouldn't pertain to zip codes well
guess what efas don't pertain to zip
codes they give a fair education
opportunity for an education for every
single kid in the state except then we
put these limits on and said only if if
you make below a certain amount of money
whether or not it means that you can
afford the education your child needs so
this
bill which
um applies to Universal eligibility for
the education Freedom account program I
would argue is the most constitutionally
Fair Way of funding our students so that
they each have that same amount of money
regardless of who they are where they
live they have that same amount of money
provided by the state to get the
education that they need thank
you uh thank you uh questions for
representative Lakers uh representative
Miler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for presenting your bill here uh
yesterday we had the executive director
of The
Children's Fund here and I asked her the
question question of the purpose of the
program and she confirmed before this
committee that the purpose of the
program is to provide opportunities
for families within a certain category
of
350% of the poverty level to be eligible
that is the purpose of the program so
would you concur with me that this
program your proposal basically changes
the purpose that was legislative by this
legislature for this program I listened
very carefully when she answered your
question and she said as it is written
now that is the purpose as the three as
it's written as
350% that is the purpose it was not the
original purpose before it got
amended original purpose was 300% no the
original purpose was no cap whatsoever
it got a mended to include a cap and to
be for poor students only and so she
very carefully answered as it is written
now this is the purpose I am saying I am
going back to the original which did not
have a cap on it and was for every
student in the state so the answer to my
qu the answer to my question is
yes the answer to my qu your question is
that yes the purpose is back to its
original
purpose further questions representative
belshire thank you Mr chair I'll ask for
just a moment of leeway this question
we'll make sense in a
moment so Civil Rights Act passed was
held to be constitutional by the Supreme
Court of the United States it was held
to be constitutional because they
decided
that um
businesses are open to the public and
therefore cannot discriminate against
those coming from the public coming as
they are now I say that because our
Constitution doesn't Define Public
School in New Hampshire so my question
to you would be do you believe that
public schools are only those schools
who are operated by the government and
government employees or are public
schools perhaps better interpreted to be
those schools who are open to the public
justi as Supreme Court held in the Civil
Rights
Act I think that would be a better
definition and we should perhaps refer
to what we call Public Schools as
Government
schools thank you uh further questions
representative cascad and maybe we can
stick to the bill with our questions
also I to thank you thank you um there's
a lot of focus on your bill on this
constitution
obviously um and I'm just wondering if
you understand or if you think um that
the language that was used in the 16 and
1700s may be different than what it is
in the other centuries in terms of the
word Seminary because if you I actually
looked that up to see what the
definition was then and it was a
religious institution of education and
there were many of them that were
founded right about the same time as our
constitution was
okay I found different then thank
you you want to take
over further questions anyone uh seeing
none thank you very much representative
thank you uh next is Megan
here thank you I think it's still
morning good morning members of
Education morning uh my name is uh for
the record my name is Megan Tuttle
president NAA New Hampshire representing
about 17,000 Educators across the state
I'm here today to express our opposition
to House Bill 1634 which would
established Universal eligibility for
Hampshire's education Freedom account
voucher program as you're aware two
recent Court decisions reaffirmed that
the state is not meeting its obligations
under our Constitution to provide an
adequate Universal public education
because the funding provided by the
state is far too low you and other
members of this committee are currently
serving on a special subcommittee to
look at legislation that could address
those decisions but several bills being
heard in House Education today beginning
with House Bill 1634 would throw open
the door to diverting more public funds
for a second private school voucher
education system where we still have yet
to fulfill our state's obligation to
adequately funding our public schools
these voucher expansion bills would take
us backwards rather than ensuring that
that every child has a highquality
public education that prepares them to
succeed in the future host Bill 1634
would divert hundreds of millions of
public dollars toward a state voucher
program that's unaccountable
discriminatory and will not provide
student achievement will ultimately harm
all students by decimating our state's
financial support for public schools
states that have recently expanded their
Voucher Program significantly or
establish Universal eligibility provide
New Hampshire and this committee with a
cautionary tale about the fiscal
consequences of funding a second
education system a recent report from
the public funds for public schools
Southern Poverty Law Center and the
education Law Center explores how
voucher programs and spending have
evolved in seven states one of the
consistent findings from the report
informs us that the context in which the
growth of voucher spending is occurring
is important at the same time funding
for vouchers has climbed considerably
these voucher State's effort to fund
public schools which serve a significant
majority of students have declined we
need need to look no further than
Arizona which recently adopted a
universal voucher program to warn us
that this policy would be unwise in New
Hampshire reaching higher New Hampshire
recent recently estimated that a
universal voucher plan could cost 105
million in fiscal year 2025 alone after
the explosion of cine in Arizona let's
not follow in their footsteps the state
of New Hampshire has a duty to better
serve the 160,000 public school students
of our state any shortfalls in the
education Trust fund are required to be
made up by the general fund which means
an Arizona style expansion would mean
other critical programs the state has
outside of Education could be
jeopardized without any kind of Revenue
source for the second education system
already New Hampshire is projected to
spend more than accounted for in this
voucher program in this fiscal year
largely new state spending because like
Arizona more than 3qu qus of the
students enrolled in the voucher program
were already in private or non-public
school setting instead of sending
taxpayer money to private schools we
should be focusing on our Public Schools
where nearly 90% of our children attend
not taking money away from them we need
to reduce class sizes we need to give
our students more one-on-one attention
we need to increase salaries to address
the teacher and staff shortages with
these questions and concerns in mind and
New Hampshire respectfully ask the house
education committee to find House Bill
1634 and expedience to legislate I
appreciate your time and attention in
reviewing our comments I do have written
and I'll be happy to take question thank
you very much are there questions from
the committee represent dry thank you Mr
chairman thank you for coming
um7 I'm cons concerned about the term
voucher that you're using could you show
me in the statutes where it says this is
a voucher program I also use
EA okay but um follow up yes all the
emails I'm getting are stop the voucher
program if you look up voucher program
it was
repealed so I'm I'm concerned that
they're working on a definition that
doesn't exist right now and maybe maybe
we're working at Cross purposes could be
thank you other questions from the
representative
Tanner thank you um when we do food
programs like Snap programs we give
vouchers and vouchers um in in
definition outside of legislative would
you agree means that a certain amount of
money is given to
people to expend uh and that money is
coming from the state thank you for the
question yes I
would represent cardelli uh thank you
thank you for being here uh you
mentioned um about uh these programs
diverting funds um maybe you could tell
us about any public schools in New
Hampshire that have not received the
amounts of money that they are entitled
to um according to current state
law thank you for the question the money
that I'm talking about when referring to
diverting funds it's money going to
students that were not in private I'm
sorry we're not in public schools
already that were already in private or
religious schools that are taking money
that could be spent so it wasn't already
going to a public school it's going
somewhere else follow up but I think
isn't the point that all public schools
are getting the money that they are
entitled to ACC according to current
state law thank you for the question
they are getting correct in saying that
they're they're getting what they're
entitled to but it needs to be a lot
more thank you uh representative Pell
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh you mentioned that
um reaching higher said that um the
education Freedom account program if if
this if this bill passed would cost
could cost taxpayers 1005 million but
currently the cost to educate a student
in the state of New Hampshire is
approximately
$20,000 the base adequacy is 4,100 so
approximately saving $116,000 per
student do you have any estimate of what
um the education Freedom accounts might
save the state thank you for the
question I don't have that on me but I
could try to find for
you uh thank you any further questions
much
Trumble
good morning again thank you committee
members I'm David Trumble from the town
aware I oppose this bill for a couple
reasons I want to start with the conval
decision I think this changes the whole
decision-making process regarding the
EFA program remember the Constitutional
Duty applies to Public Schools that's
stated in the Constitution it was also
specifically stated in the Claremont
decision and again in all of the
subsequent Supreme Court decisions we're
not meeting that obligation we're giving
4200 base Aid the judge said we need at
least 7500 probably more like
$10,000 the Constitutional Duty comes
first before we spend any more money on
alternative education we have to live up
to our constitutional duties first so
until you fund that I don't think we can
fund any additional money for
efas last year we testified and said
this and somebody said well but we are
living up to our duty so now we can
spend extra money on efas the judge
finally documented how much we're not
living up to our duty so I think until
you actually live up to that Duty which
would cost us $500 million we don't have
$100 million left for efas second we are
not obligated to spend a penny on the
EFA program there's no constitutional
Duty that applies to private schools
that's clearly not in our constitution
or the Claremont decision
the US Supreme Court in the Caren versus
Mon case said as we held in espanosa
another case similar case a state need
not subsidize private education there's
no New Hampshire or us constitutional
duty to spend public education so what
you could do and remember now the 4200
that you're giving to each EFA is not
constitutionally linked that was a
legislative convenience so what you
could do is say conille says we have to
go up to 7,500 we're going to pass that
we're going to live up to that and keep
the EFA amount at 4,200 there's no
reason they have to remain tied forever
and ever into the future Additionally
the state has the constitutional right
to put other restrictions on EFA funding
in that Carson vers Mak case you know
that's the case in Maine where the state
was funding some private schools and
denied money to all religious schools
judge Roberts wrote that it's wrong to
say as the denters do that under our
decision today Maine must fund religious
educ ation as we held in espanosa a
state need not subsidize private
education but once a state decides to do
so it cannot disqualify some private
schools solely because they're religious
emphasis on the word solely the state
doesn't have to provide funds to
religious schools or to private schools
if you do fund private schools you can't
say no to every religious school but you
could say no to some religious schools
or any private school for specific
reasons for instance if they had racist
policies you could legitimately as the
state of New say we won't fund them
there are there was a university in the
US that had a ban on interracial dating
as recently as the century we're living
in if a private school had that policy
in New Hampshire you would all say we
won we don't want our EFA funding to go
to that I think we can all agree there
are limits we don't have to give EFA
funds to every single private school
that brings up the question they
discriminate against children with
disabilities they discriminate against
children who are lgbtq why can't the
state also say we will give you money
but you have to live up to basic civil
rights last least the question about
saving money there's about 4,000
children in the EFA program 75% go to
private schools there's only 1,000 who
left the public school to go to a
private school there's 180 school
districts in the state that basically
means five or six students in each
School District participate who from
went from a public school that's one
child per School how can that possibly
save any money you you have a fourth
grade with two classes 25 kids in each
room losing one student doesn't save
that that school a penny people who
assert that it does it's time for them
to put up some evidence so that the
people of New Hampshire can look at your
flowcharts and see where's the savings
because right now there is no savings
that's all I have thank you thank you
any further questions
for testifier no thank you thank you
wilky
good morning um Mr chair and members of
the committee thank you for having me
I'm Mary Wilkey I live in conquered and
I'm a retired school teacher public
school teacher um I just I want to
reiterate without repeating that I also
agree that uh until New Hampshire Liv us
its constitutional obligation to fully
fund our Public Schools it really has
should not be giving away ever
increasing amounts of money to private
and uh schools and other educational
vendors um I assume that the reason the
legislature has never complied with
Claremont is because it's expensive but
if we have the money if we have money
lying around to give to private schools
then that money should be going to
Public Schools according to our New
Hampshire Supreme Court which is the
body that gets to interpret the law I
often disagree with Court decisions but
they're the ones under our constitution
who get to decide
um I feel like it's kind of like if a
parent was ordered to pay child you know
$1,000 in child support every month and
they were only paying 200 and then they
were also giving money to the kid down
the street it's just not it's just not
the way it should be uh last Wednesday
when the school funding bills were're
being heard testimony from a public
school principal whose school doesn't
have running water here in New Hampshire
in the United States of America a public
school with now running water we heard
from students who couldn't go to college
because their school couldn't offer
language classes or they couldn't get
into certain colleges because of that uh
the idea that the legislature might let
those conditions continue to exist but
be willing to write a check to a
millionaire who's paying the 60,000 or
whatever tuition at Philips exitor which
has a $1.2 billion um uh endowment fund
the idea that we would write a check to
that person and not fix the problems
that exist in public schools because of
a uh insufficient funding just strikes
me as just outrageously
wrong uh the legislative oversight
committee has uh created a list of
questions they'd like to see answered
and and addressed and there hasn't you
that just came out November 30th the
first report of an oversight committee
how could how can we go forward and
expand this program without considering
what they came up with uh we don't know
what's happening to some there quite a
few kids I think it's maybe oh sorry I'm
not good at remembering numbers but a
lot of kids who are referred to as other
exits they've left the program not going
to public school not
graduating where do they go what
happened to them we don't even know that
uh there's a lot of questions that need
to be answered by the Department of
Education with all these questions out
there why would we expand the program I
what's the rush at least find out have
the audit consider what the oversight
committee came up with and then think
about it thank you thank you um
questions uh representative beler thank
you Mr chair thank you for the testimony
have this I know it's written
away
um if I understand correctly the
significant amount of your argument
hinges on the your assertion that you
just made that the the
court um decisions that we have that
we're working on here that within our
constitution the court has been given
the sole authority to interpret
Constitution and law so on that can you
can you expound a little bit as to
exactly where in our constitution the
court is delegated the sole
responsibility of interpreting the
Constitution and law and how if they are
in fact Superior to both other branches
of government in that way we could
possibly be a
republic well I can't I I don't have the
New Hampshire constitution in front of
me but my understanding from going to
public school and going to college Etc
is that uh we have three branches of
government that are co-equal and that
they each have their own areas and that
the legislature makes the laws and the
con and the courts interpret the laws
and the uh executive department uh uh
Branch enforces the laws and so I I
imagine I could find it if I had it but
I don't have it in my
brain any further questions seean thank
you very much for being
here um lastly uh Matt Southerton um
from children's scholarship fund is here
for technical support if requested I I
do have a couple of questions I'm not
does hey good
morning Matt suton from children's
scholarship fund thank you for being
here um I Rec call from some of our
education oversight EFA oversight
committee meetings um there was some
information about uh the number of um uh
students who have left the program for
reasons other than graduation uh do you
have any do you have that data handy I I
don't yes other exits I was just looking
at that as a matter of fact since that's
come up we've given that um information
to the department we've also given that
to the legislative oversight committee I
was just looking at that
so the reason that that um came up as
525 other exits is because that
information was from the beginning of
the year report that the department had
so they didn't have all the information
um 164 of those students were delayed in
submitting their application 94 of those
students were in the process of
submitting their
application um 11
students were delayed in reapplying but
they were not exited and and I can send
this all to you but right yeah the
majority of those students were just in
the process of submitting their
application or not submitted it at the
time um I'll take a followup okay sorry
about that that's okay um thank you uh
um so what was the the bottom line
number in then uh when you subtract
those from the original 500 uh plus um I
I remember hearing a much smaller
number uh so the the number of students
that actually left the program was 107
out of that
525 okay and the total number of
students who were in the program at that
point was
that that was the 4500 number 4500
number
okay uh represent
Tanner thank you can you give us more
information about why the audit is isn't
being done and why it it started in 22
and still isn't being done are we
talking about our annual audit that's
completed I'm talking about the uh HP
1135 the audit that was uh put into law
for LBA yes yeah so they are currently
in the process of starting that the
Department of Education has contacted us
and LBA I believe they're in the Pro
process of contacting us they've asked
us for um the
key key um contact information for for
the key players at Children's
scholarship fund the key individuals and
we we have given them that information
follow yes so the holdup is with LBA is
that what you're saying no I mean I I
assume that they're just beginning that
process now we were just contracted last
week okay but this this audit was
supposed to be done in O finished by
October of last
year I can't speak LBA or the department
okay thank
you um you mentioned another audit you
you do an annual audit correct yeah as
required by law CSF is supposed to
report is supposed to perform an annual
audit and that's done and all those
website further questions representative
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for your technical support on this um so
as the laws written cut off is 350% of
federal poverty level for access to this
program correct um do we have numbers
either in terms of exact numbers or even
percentages as to how many New Hampshire
children would under current law be
refused access to this program based on
that number so I pinged the the the
application team and we so to date we've
only had about 250 students that have
applied but that are not eligible for
the EFA program because they didn't meet
that cut
off and just quick follow follow if I
may um that's that's very good
information do we do we know as far is
just demographic Statewide how many
students would be yeah sorry I don't
have that data okay thank
you R tar thank you um do you know how
many students that are currently in the
program because they don't have to
recertify their eligibility have
actually gone to 350% or higher yeah I
don't have that data but approximately
50 % of the students in the program
currently have to read certify each year
because about 44% of the students uh
currently received the free and reduced
lunch eligibility requirement and then
about 7% are students with um special
needs um so then each year those
students have to re-qualify so that they
can get that disparity Aid and a follow
up on that yes and so it you have that
information and and if they go
beyond uh the current um limit of
eligibility they're
still correct they would still be
eligible for the program because they
are grandfathered in according to the
questions represent Miler well thank you
just a clarification so you're saying
that
currently because there's a bill pending
before this committee hasn't heard yet
you're saying that 45% of those students
that are currently in the program have
to reapply each year they they actually
do yes that so the the the students that
qualify for the free and reduced lunch
disp dispari a they receive those extra
money so they do have to submit their
financial their financial documents each
year and then our application team has
to go over that and and make sure that
they meet that eligibility requirement
of 350% or less in order to receive
those additional Monies
so if they do not if they're not
eligible for it then they would not
receive those additional monies no thank
much represent Tanner when you say they
don't receive the additional money so
they don't receive the additional money
for the free and reduced but they still
receive the additional money for the EFA
or the children's scholarship correct
they would be they would be
grandfathered into the program right for
for just the the EFA State adequacy and
the reapplication is merely for the
funds for free and reduced or special ed
correct okay thank
you are there any further
questions thank you very much we have no
further cards in this one so we're going
to close
1167 or excuse me
you okay we're going to go ahead and
quickly do 1167 this should not take
very long uh I will introduce the bill
and represent cordelli will chair the
hearing is anyone else
need to copy the bill by any chance no
that okay we'll open the hearing on
House Bill 1167 relative to the math
learning communities program and we uh
welcome back chairman Le
thank you very much Representative
cordelan members of the education
committee I'm here today to speak on
1167 this is relative to the math
learning communities program which I I
put in on behalf of the community
college system New Hampshire uh we've
talked often about the uh math learning
communities and I I can go through and
briefly explain it um it's a program in
which we after the um students are have
their Algebra 1 class in the spring of
of of their 10th grade we work with the
parent the student uh folks within the
school that are teaching the
mathematics and we try to discern if the
student is ready to go on to Algebra 2
if they really have a good focus on that
mathematics um if they
don't they they go into what we call a
foundation math program which is set up
in conjunction with the original grant
that we got in Beth Dorian from the
community college system worked with
that for years and we had 38 or so high
schools involved with this program we
stopped the grant stopped from which
they had received at the community
college system that program kind of died
until we allocated $200,000 to continue
it and and so now we have it we're ready
to move forward so following the 10th
grade if we have a student that doesn't
you know really grasp the and and
understand the algebra one and and and
and so they go into that foundational
math class in 11th grade and then they
have the opportunity to go into
quantitative math in the 12th grade it's
a it's a program which is providing
instruction differently than you would
see in the algebra 2 class however from
passing the quantitative math you have
sufficiently accomplished what is
required for your math requirement when
you go into the community college system
so you don't have to have that remedial
mathematics which we know that we had at
1.60% of the students going into the
community college system needed remedial
math and now they don't do it as
remedial math they work with the
individual student in the holes that
that student has and trying to uh help
that that that student with th those
subject area or elements within the
mathematics to get them on board uh
while they're at the community college
system and the issue why this is coming
forward is that the test which we used
at the end of 10th grade and it was
called the uh accuplacer um uh what was
it
the the Next Generation accupure uh test
examination is no longer used by the
community college system and they're
using other assessment tools now and
that's what we like to do it because
there's a number of assessments are also
done locally which do the same thing to
discern if a child is having child
student is having difficulty with
algebra 1 and really doesn't understand
it and needs that alternative path way
if we don't do this the issue is we have
students that go on and they learn not
to enjoy mathematics and their potential
um is lost in the workforce and this is
a course that a program which is really
finally needed we know that our
achievement scores in mathematics in the
state are not where we want them even
though we're comparing to other states
we're doing well but you know that bar
New Hampshire has pride in saying we we
want to be the best
and so we want no child to be left
behind and and to move forward with this
program and I'd be glad to take any any
questions any questions representative
Tanner thank you um I'm just I'm after
doing the dyslexia work I am really
concerned with and I I've known students
who just they they freak out when they
see numbers I mean that's how bad um you
know they're uh learning at that
learning stage at that point is and um
there is a disc
calcula um diagnosis where students are
very very similar they can't they can't
mathematically deal with numbers at at
that point they can't code um is there
any do you know of any work that's being
done be because it have to be done
before 10th grade I I would assume um to
approach this or to to try to you know
know give some help to these students I
I know that is an issue that even your
your elementary teachers and your
principles there and superintendents are
cognizant of and in the district I'm in
in sau23 Lori malanson who is the
superintendent of schools she
is UN she's rebaking the whole math
program to address this type of issue
and so they're they're writing a new
curriculum in how they teach and uh I
think this is something which is more
than just one District I think we're all
recognizing after the task force that
was set up by Paul leather years ago he
was the Deputy Commissioner and that was
at least now 14 years or 12 years ago it
was recognized that we have two many
students which are not doing what they
should be doing in mathematics and it
was seen that as a result of our
achievement test at time at that time
showed that after the junior high school
level those grades seven and eight there
was that huge waterfall effect as far as
student uh achievement in in mathematics
it goes obviously back into the
Elementary grades it's not just laid
down on those Junior High teachers or
them or the high school teachers and um
it it's it's uh something which this
program right here has helped do that in
fact the the professional training for
these teachers that are teaching this
this math communities program are
teachers that have been taught by
teachers that have implemented this
program so they bring them in the
summertime Community College oversees
this and we're trying to get more people
trained in this but those people go back
into the schools and they're working
with the Math teachers and elementary
teachers prior that so I think this is a
a a good program that we need to
continue and we just need to modify to
allow this new assessment that they want
to use but this is an area that I think
that the district district schools the
public schools are aware of and trying
to address and often times it's like
when I met with a group of teachers down
in Riven Riven uh Riv
rivendale that that's fairly in Corinth
Vermont with Orford New Hampshire it's
an interstate District I pulled all the
math teachers together and I asked the
question and back when we were talking
about multiplication
facts they were diametrically opposed
these teachers from each other you know
one was saying oh no it's all conceptual
you don't have to memorize the other
ones in the high school saying you
better know those things when you come
into these classes and so they weren't
talking with each other and I think
that's what we have to you start if
curriculum is a responsibility The Local
District and instruction you got to talk
with each other and they got the hint uh
that yes the math teacher who is the
math teacher at the high school is also
working with all those that just like a
coach the coach uh for athletic in the
high school the varsity coach often
times oversees the JV coach and
everything else going on in the Middle
School level if you want to have a
decent program so to have a decent
program math we got to do the same thing
I think that's happening representa
Tanner I think that's an ongoing process
and people learn differently and I know
I myself was one of those I can remember
my f only grade I remember in elementary
school what's my first grade teacher
called me up the board I was shy didn't
want to read didn't know to spell I
threw up right in front of her and and
and uh so it's uh you know there's
teaching styles and there's learning
styles and this program matches teaching
style and learning style that's an
important part of
Education further questions yes
representative Cornell Thank you thank
you for taking my question um the math
assessment is that is it a universal
assessment that will be used in every
school or districts are going to be able
to use their own to determine if the
student needs it's done in coopera with
the community college system in New
Hampshire thank you they're the
coordinators of this program okay thank
you very much Shannon Reed from the
community college system is here also so
any further questions representative
Belcher thank you Mr chair and thank you
for the bill uh agree with the general
concept I have one question on I'm not
sure about on on language so it
specifically identifies two groups of
students those students who are not yet
demonstrating uh competency and also
those who have demonstrated Mass y but
is there such a thing as a student who
has demonstrated competency but not yet
Mastery and would that student be
excluded from higher level math I think
this gets to what represent Tanner was
speaking to also that there's different
learning styles and you you can have
students which
um Can conceptualize or or something
that can
memorize and and you really don't know
how to apply and in order to to learn
how to apply it's just like in CTE
programs you learn by doing you learn
how to make that cabinet you learn how
to you know fix that automobile um but
through doing it and that's what this
program does it works with the student
so we have students in there this is not
um a a program that's set up for those
which you have difficult time you know
in all subject area this is where
there's a lot of students come out of
elementary school and you ask them
what's your favorite course and they'll
say yeah recess and then they may say
physical education or something such as
that but there's not a whole lot of
people come through students come
through saying mathematics is my
favorite subject and um it's pretty
common and so somewhere along the way
they're getting turned off to it and and
uh everything we do is
mathematical so um I hope that answers a
little bit what you're after thanks yeah
see no further questions thank you very
Reed good afternoon education committee
my name is Shannon Reed I'm here on
behalf of the community college system
of New Hampshire um the prime sponsor
did most of my work for me this morning
by explaining the history of the program
um the the kind of Genesis of it and
what we seek with this bill I'll just
say a couple things um first I'm sorry
that it's me here today and not my
colleague Beth Doran who had been at
running this program overseeing the
program and she knows so much more about
the details than I do so I'll do my best
to answer any questions that you might
have um we're very excited to be
restarting this program it was initially
funded through a grant a Federal grant
that lasted for maybe four or five years
um but it was focused on Innovation that
Grant so once this program became kind
of entrenched even though it was proven
to be successful
through metrics and student outcomes in
that it was no longer um an innovation
the grant funding dried up and so we're
we're very grateful that in hital 2 this
program was funded so that we could
restart it it's um it's got a number of
of important benefits one was alluded to
in the a previous conversation which is
the communication and collaboration it
creates between um the secondary level
mathematics instructors and Community
College mathematics instructors kind of
helping each other see what are what are
you what are you teaching how are you
teaching it at the college level what
are we seeing in the math preparedness
of students who come directly from high
schools to our colleges and so I think
that's a huge benefit um also of course
the creation of the two math classes
that students can take that um that
address that address the competencies
that students need to place into college
level math and then the more advanced
course can actually be taken as a dual
credit course so students can get credit
for that first gateway Math course in
college so there's a lot of benefits the
results of the program when it was
funded and in place were were very
positive I'm afraid I don't have those
details but um um the the performance
the persistence the completion rates of
students who took these courses was was
very much approved over what had been
what had been the case before um so in
this bill um we're we're seeking to
basically have the statutory language
reflect the practice which is evolved
Beyond simp using one test the
accuplacer test and one cut score as the
determining factor in in how students
Place into math and this gets a little
bit to your question of Competency
versus Mastery using multiple measures
is really a better practice it's evolved
to be a better practice than using one
maybe kind of high stakes test that
student may or may not do particularly
well on in on a given day so using
multiple measures to assess student
Readiness for the the courses um is is
the better prac practice than using one
one test um also we're broadening the
language for that second higher level
course from Simply quantitative
reasoning to something that might
Encompass or might include um other
additional kind of focus areas and we
we've in restarting the program we've
created a a math learning communities
Advisory Group made up of high school
instructors College instructors the math
consultant for the Department of
Education and this this group is going
to in broadening their work um determine
what the what the best curricular
components of that second level course
are um so I I can probably stop there
and see if you have any specific
questions um I I would say actually a
couple a couple things in conclusion
um a number of years back there was a
lot of concern over the lack of kind of
consistent and strong math preparedness
math Readiness of high school graduates
who were coming to to to particularly
our colleges but really any any
postsecondary education
um the community college system did two
main things to respond to to that kind
of situation one is we created this this
program math learning communities the
partnership with high schools and two we
we changed How We Do developmental math
education once students get to College
back 20 years ago if a student didn't
Place into college level math we would
put them in what was then called
remedial math or medial Math course um
not college credit bearing basically
repeating topics that they um had in
theory covered in high school it took
their time it took their money and um
the outcomes metrics were were not not
favorable for students who had to be in
remedial math if you had you know for
any 10 students who got placed into
remedial math the number who persisted
and completed a a credential a degree or
certificate was very small um nationally
there they're revolved a better practice
and that's called co-requisite
remediation and that is identifying
specifically what challenges students
had in math putting those students into
college level math but giving them extra
supports in those areas um so the
students are they're in college math
they're feeling that sense of
achievement they're getting support
where they need it and that that barrier
remedial math became a barrier where it
was supposed to be a bridge but we
created what was a true bridge to
success in a college curriculum um so so
that's this bill is basically just
updating the language of the statute to
kind of reflect current practice I would
suggest you might consider one very
minor Amendment which is simply to make
this bill effective upon passage there's
no need for a 60-day um kind of adoption
time period so um that's not highly
consequential but if it's easy enough to
do we would um that would certainly work
well for us thank you and I'm happy to
try to answer any questions any
questions representative cascaden thank
you Mr chair and thank you for your
presentation I believe in the in the
system and in the process um my question
is is there a cost to the local school
district to be a
partner um I think the the short answer
is no but there's there are probably
some I guess I would call them in kind
costs so the the
funding the funding in houseal 2 for
this program is $200,000 a year what
that pays for are course materials
testing materials when we use those like
like when we did use the accuplacer
um the paying a part-time coordinator
that we employ and bringing together in
an annual convening all of these folks
all these instructors from the various
schools and the various levels to kind
of facilitate that cross-pollination um
so we cover the cost of that but you
know the schools may may be incurring
some type of cost for participation of
their folks I'm not certain about that
but I will ask my colleague Beth and I
can get back to
you
rent beler thank you Mr chair and thank
you for being here for this um I believe
I heard you that you want to ultimately
transition away from the current one
high stakes test to a more um a system
where you could have multiple
assessments being done but the specific
language I'm seeing in this bill only
makes provision for a mathematics
assessment not multiple so is that
something you would like to see changed
slightly to allow for for multiple
assessments instead of just the one
um
yeah I I I guess I think either way I
think we could interpret a mathematics
assessment to be inclusive of multiple
measures okay
fair further
questions see none thank you very much
for being here and um that will close uh
the hearing on House Bill
and
um break for lunch what's the time we
supposed to be back one you want to make
it 1:15 I think
1:00
well see you
tomorrow that's your partner
much
good
e
jr7
Bas the thank you chairman members of
Education House Education I'm here to
testify in favor of HB
1677 also known as the every student
loves education achievement and
reforming neglectful schools act the
every student learns
act I think everybody in this room is
interested in making sure the children
educated in the state of New Hampshire
have the best possible
education that's the goal one would hope
that this committee is fully engaged in
supportive of that
goal the bill is a is a redo to the
definitions that are currently under
chapter 194 DF
d-f as in Frank education Freedom
accounts and current definition is under
Section Roman numeral 6 it's eligible
student this bill repeals and reenacts
that section um following the same
policies that are currently in six with
one major exception I will get to that
major
exception so although it's a repeal and
replace there's no bold to make it easy
to read section A of this act is
identical to what's in current law this
is students who are eligible to receive
the education Freedom accounts relative
to 300 50% which is the current
policy I will come back to section B uh
section c I believe is also in the law
somewhere um I don't remember where I
didn't see it um but this is someone
this is a student who tried to get to
another school and their school district
denied them and then following current
policy students who participated this in
this current year okay can continue to
participate in the future that's that's
been the ongoing policy
so let's talk about section B CU that is
in fact the new
section and this has to do with how well
the school district is
performing we have made this about
whether the parents can afford to give
their children another option well
that's a great metric I think it is an
inadequate metric it is the wrong
metric currently we send our children in
the public schools based on two criteria
what ZIP code they live in and what year
they were born
it has nothing to do with it right
academic skill
level whether they're an exemplary
student and and and should be in an
honors program whether they have a
learning style that is visual versus
Hands-On versus auditory I I'm sure
there are a bunch of teachers in here
who who could better speak to education
learning styles than I can that's not
how we send kids to school we send kids
to school on zip code and birthday
that's
it the problem is the parents have no
option they're told go to the local
school I'm going to pick on on on the
largest city in Manchester today because
I have that particular data up the
Department of Education has created a
bunch of reports under their website
under the IR report I believe is the
correct one you can look up the school
performance for any District in the
state and I'm going to use Manchester as
it encompasses the largest number of
students in one particular
28% 28% of the students at whatever
grade level they're using for testing
I'm assuming this is their eighth grade
test but it could be
others okay are considered proficient in
the English
language 19% are proficient in math and
14% are proficient in
science well it's good that we spent a
lot of additional or sent a lot of
additional money
to um Manchester in hb2 last year to the
tune of something like $35 million of
additional funding those scores are not
sufficient to prepare our children for
the future we need to do a better
job today if a school isn't doing well
we send them more money that is how we
incentivize schools if you look at the
schools and they're doing poorly we pick
up and we we know we send them
additional money um to help their their
children do better
unfortunately that rewards at some level
bad behavior not bad behavior of the
student but bad behavior of the system
to educate the
children we should in fact find schools
that are doing really really well and
make sure that they we fund them well so
they can educate more children because
you might find um I'm part of Dunbarton
my children are homeschooled so it
doesn't apply to me but if my children
were in Dunbarton and we were sending to
gown but B was doing better we might
want our kids in the bow school system
for and as a town we made that
decision so that the children are public
part of the public school system could
go to Bo for a better education Our Town
decided to do that they left the gos
toown district and went to about but not
every parent can do that and if you have
to tuition into the other District
this would allow you to have access to
help financial help to do
that so all this bill does is ADD
section B and it talks about if the
school is not doing a good job making
sure the children are educated the
parents have another option that option
can be any other education it can be
another Public School it can be a
private school it can be homeschool all
the things are available through the
efas the only metric that is is is
used is what is the school doing in
terms of performance is it meeting a
reasonable threshold the reasonable
threshold that I picked for this bill
was that less than half the students are
proficient we canjust that number maybe
that number's too high maybe we should
said it is only 10% of the students are
proficient or sorry our failing
proficiency maybe it should be 90 I
don't know we can we can have a
discussion on what that metric is in my
eyes if half the if half the children
are not proficient in the various
subject matters we have not done our job
as a state to prepare them for their
future with that I'll close my testimony
um I'm willing to answer any
questions very
much yeses thank you thank you and as a
Manchester rep I would like to ask you
are you saying that Manchester school
district is not teaching their children
as well as they could
because they want to get more funds from
the state and not taking into account
the percentage of students that we have
that are English language Learners um
special
education um
disadvantaged I'm not saying that it's
that is what you said you said
Manchester
is rewarded for their children doing
poorly on this test and are being
incentivized by low scor to get more
money from the
state so I'm going to take this as a
question and the question was did I say
that Manchester intentionally does this
no Manchester is not intentionally doing
it I'm saying the current statutes and
the law and the system incentivizes this
whether or not that's an intended
consequence or an unintended
consequence we send additional money to
districts that are doing poorly that is
how we treat districts that is a fact
I'm not saying that is the policy that
we want I'm just saying that is the fact
and one of the UN unintended
consequences of policies like that is we
end up with children aren't doing this
well we should look at the Academy for
Science and design where they have yes
it's a charter school they get to select
the students that are participating but
look they are they are top nationally in
one of the as one of the high schools in
the state this is what we should be
rewarding this is what we should be be
incentivizing more
of well not being able to choose what
students attend public schools in
Manchester because we welcome them all
and we do have a large large population
of English language Learners special
education um and somebody this morning
said that Berlin had 60% free and
reduced lunch which was large well
Manchester schools are way above that so
I don't think that they're doing
poorly is being incentified by
incentified by anything that the state
is giving them to score poorly I'm sure
they'd rather get less money and have
um children do
well so the the good news is right
through House Bill 2 last year the state
budget we made fundamental changes in
how the state reimbursed local school
districts through the swep
account for various things including
free and reduced lunch and in the end
some of the larger cities Manchester and
Nashville in particular I don't know
Berlin I I don't remember the numbers
for all the towns in the state saw a
significant increase in disparity level
aid because of right English Learners
right free and reduced lunch right lower
income households um I get that and
maybe the the scores we're seeing today
are a result of under fing for years I
don't know but I am saying right
now those percentages in terms of scores
are not we are not doing a job our job
as a state educating our children if you
look at over time how well we have done
to other um industrialized nations first
world Nations we have continued to drop
in terms of our education performance
for the last several decades we have to
reverse that Trend this is one way to do
it
thank you so
proficiency what do you think
proficiency is is it 60% 70% 80% 90% or
100% if in the old terms because we're
using this term proficient so in Old
terms with with going to school was it
an A B C D E was it I would argue that
it should
be a 70% or better
higher than that it's higher than that
from the State Department of Education
So when you say proficient you're not
talking and and you're throwing it
around like they're barely passing
proficient means that they're up in the
80% range and that's a high bar for most
kids so you know to throw around the the
term proficient and to have
48% in proficient is is something that's
p in in the sky really it's Pie in the
Sky depending and particularly for some
place like Manchester Now Now options in
Manchester you have how many charter
schools in
Manchester okay parents have options in
in
Manchester parents have
options okay
so as far as the proficiency part of
this bill and the fact that you said
that parents have no options I think is
it is not not right not not truthful so
if I may follow up to that question what
is the right percentage if you're saying
it's 85 at what percentage of students
should be achieving 85% proficiency I
think uh a c uh a c is average yes okay
and I think a c average grade if if most
of your students at your school are
doing C or above and you're always going
to have some kids that are at the top of
the top of the span you're always going
to get a few kids that are at the bottom
of the scan that's how it works okay and
and Manchester with all the issues that
they have any school with any issues
that they have and depending year to
year to year I mean and like you said
some of it is you can't throw say that
you threw 35 million at them last year
and that this year they should should be
48% proficient that that's unreasonable
that is I understand that statement and
right can support that you can't
fundamentally change by 30% the the
Proficiency in a single year relative to
funding but I do believe we should have
far more
than 10% of the kids at 85% or better if
you're using
85 in my eyes 25% of the students should
be b or higher level work if they're
doing and it's only because of how the
tests are set up and this is relative to
the National capability we we have New
Hampshire has since I sat on education
in
20112 okay has been one of the states
with a better education system can we do
better absolutely relative to other
industrialized nations we're not doing
that well anymore we are not preparing
our our children for the future and
that's what needs to be
fixed what was the what was the
proficiency level question yeah just
what what was the proficiency level of
Manchester 28% in English that's above
10 19 in math and 14 in science right so
10% further
question thank you and thank you for
being here um it's unfortunate that in
the last 30 years this legislature has
failed to meet its obligation according
to the Court decisions around school
funding so that's just just to say it
question that I the question I have for
you is that as I read
B If This Were to become
law the only qualifications for a uh
family who wants to have an EFA would be
that they would be in the 40%
49% or in
48% proficiency and there'd be no other
qualifications so there'd be no 350 you
don't have to qualify from a standpoint
of income or anything like that it's
basically what the proficiency level
would be of that district is that
correct that is correct this is this is
about school district performance and if
the children aren't getting the
education they need that additional
[Music]
available thank you Mr chair thank you
taking my
question so could you comment please
since there is no testing or assessment
standard for students educated through
NFA If This Were to pass how would we
know that they were becoming more
proficient than in their current Public
Schools so in most cases with EFA it
does not cover the 100% of the net of
the costs of right going to an outside
thing right so if the parents don't see
the performance they want the parents
themselves would choose to go back to
the public education system because they
don't have to write a check for the
difference unless that because they are
now an active consumer meaning they're
looking at their performance they're
looking at how their children are doing
in the school if they don't see an
increase in in how their children are
doing right there's no reason for them
to continue to write
checks
you so if I'm understanding you
correctly you don't see any relevance or
need for there to be more objective than
parental
observation of the results of this
education system that is at least partly
tax Fair
funded so I am a strong proponent for
free market Solutions where the
consumers have some say in what they
what they buy and because of that they
use their money
wisely and in this case it's the parents
who are looking at how well their
children are doing and I do believe
since the parents are writing the check
they're the consumers right they're not
they're not being educated but they're
the ones making the purchase that they
will do what is best for their
children and because of that they will
be very attentive to yes my children are
learning or not learning in moving to
the school I didn't see any additional
progress right they're they're not up to
what I believe is a reasonable standard
and there for they would choose not to
continue thank you for your
answer thank you Mr chair and thank you
rep hole um we've heard a lot about
proficiency and larger populations but
I'd like to get a little bit more
granular um so we're talking proficiency
and this bill would allow students at
schools that are of low Prof proficiency
to be able to go elsewhere can you can
you imagine that in a school tool that
is generally of low proficiency and
would likely therefore need to spend a
considerable amount of time and effort
into remediation and improving uh those
scores and uh proficiencies that there
might be students who are proficient
perhaps having mastered subjects and are
possibly even gifted who could be left
behind and not meet their full potential
in such an environment absolutely thank
you
thank you thank you representative for
being here
um is the uh 49% proficiency level um
criteria for uh Ela or science or math e
any one of those three they would
qualify that is how it is currently
drafted right they are those three
options are ored together right um and I
did that because you might have a
student who wants to be a stem major
right where either math or science is is
insufficient for them to achieve their
curriculum thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question um your your
statistics are the 49% of the schools
that's your criteria but there could be
students within those schools that are
highing that are scoring higher and
doing fine in those
schools correct that is I think
representative beler just made that
comment you might you might have a
student who is doing very well in that
school okay whose parents want them to
do
better so well conversely you could look
at it the other way there could be
students that are in higher uh schools
higher achieving schools that are doing
poorly that is true as well right I I
think the point is as a as a whole that
school system is is has some average
performance and that average performance
is a great metric to figure out whether
parents should have other options back
to my opening remarks we currently
assign school districts based on two
criteria zip code and age that's it not
learning style not learning capability
or aptitude not historic performance not
what kind of career they want any of the
other reasonable metrics to figure out
how to educate somebody we're not using
those we're using zip code and
age um and I think everybody has a
unique learning style we tend to put
them in large buckets right some are
auditory learn Learners some are
Hands-On some are visual Learners I'm
sure there's somebody here who has much
greater skills in terms of describing
those learning styles but at the end of
the day we want our children to do the
best possible right to have the best
them not see anything thank you
education
sure uh this will go into EX session for
House Bill
1167 relative to math learning
communities program I'd like to make a
motion of P
1167 second by Resident
Cornell yep
sure it's good this clerk says hold it
though
I made the
motion now okay we just go through the
roll
call okay ready okay
this to you madam clerk I have no
discussion on it
right
representative Cordell yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
Noble
yes representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner
yes representative
Hall oh
okay representative Al Bon
yes and representative
cascaden the question is House Bill 11
communities no we're
voting sorry I just needed cop did you
too okay
1167 uh yes okay thank you
representative Damon
yes all right that's
12 I'll chairman lad yes thank you very
much been a while uh 13 yays zero Nays
and one two three four five six seven
missing great so this will be on consent
and we're going to close the executive
session back on task we start in 10
minutes for the next bill schedule at
1:45 okay see got a pink card yes great
thank
you one here thank
you oh okay I got it then
so yeah it's
[Music]
this
Joe
why I don't know which one of the cfort
go
okay okay now I got to find the right
she exactly I mean because I think I
morning 1561 coming up uh yeah yeah yeah
y
thank you very much Mr chairman and
members of the House Education committee
uh my name is representative Joe Sweeney
I represent Rockingham 25 it's the town
of Salem um I did uh email you all
earlier a copy of my introductory
testimony um and I gave a copy to the
clerk and I won't uh simply read off the
letter but I'll try to just speak from
from the heart here uh I I sit before
you as the proud product of our New
Hampshire Public Schools uh and really I
would only be here because of the public
schools in our state when I was four
years old I could only coherently
communicate 27 words uh and I required
three years of extensive speech therapy
to get caught up with my peers uh in
order to uh speak and communicate well
uh among my age group um and I received
Reed that therapy through the Salem
School District through the seed program
and I'm very proud of that school
district I'm very proud of that program
uh it's a program that continu to this
day in the town of Salem and our schools
uh and it it's it's those sorts of
investments in our community uh that are
cherish in the granite state and and
truly is the only reason I haven't
really stopped talking since I took my
speech therapy um when I four to seven
uh but it is really the only way that I
am here today uh which is in support of
of HB
1561 uh when I think of our our wildly
successful education Freedom accounts
program I want to make sure that we can
take the next steps to ensure that
students that might not feel safe in
their school districts or students that
are not currently being successful have
the options to take advantage of our
educational Freedom accounts uh so that
they can pursue education that matters
uh and works for them in Salem for me
that was education that was provided by
my local uh public Public School
District however I I fully recognize
that Salem as a very property rich town
uh is not representative of the state
when it comes to what is being offered
and what is available to students
throughout New Hampshire uh which is
what this category uh type bill for
qualifications really does seek to do
there's a number of qu of categories in
this bill uh that we would expand
coverage of the education Freedom
accounts too um and it was really as I
talked to the co-sponsors of the bill
and stakeholders uh a list of categories
that would best benefit from access to
educational Freedom accounts if for
whatever reason they feel unsafe in
their school districts so they feel that
their schools are not providing them the
the tools to succeed necessary hence
there are elements here of of
standardized test scores being factored
in at the school district level and the
individual student uh to qualify for
educational Freedom accounts um as well
as different categories of mental health
of how the student identifies of how
that student uh what the district has to
offer if there's a contamination in the
school district of pasas uh or if if the
student or their family is afraid of
catching a disease at the school
district that they can then apply and
qualify for educational Freedom accounts
uh I'm happy to take any questions of it
I did detail this all in the testimony
that I sent over I don't want to
certainly be duplicative of that process
um but I'm happy to take any questions
from the committee as you see fit and I
know there were others here to talk as
well very much your speech paist did a
good job thank you this they did
question uh thank you Mr chair thank you
for being there and I'm glad you were a
success out of Salem uh as I'm look at
several these
categories uh it seems to me that many
of these categories would fall into a
manifest hardship situation which we
currently have in school districts and
superintendents do exercise that now I
don't think whether the p fast for
example that wouldn't I don't think that
would
qualify but clearly The Bullying the the
sexual
orientation um others would already
qualify for a parent to deal with a
school system to have that their child
plac in another are you aware of the
Manifest hardship I I am aware of it and
I think it's a great precedent for this
bill to make those students eligible for
educational Freedom accounts regardless
um are do you know whether uh all the
places that the person could use the
efas would be willing to accept these
people I I don't see any reason uh why
not why they would not um and I believe
if we empower the parents to make that
decision with their education uh it
would not only over open up more
opportunities in New Hampshire for
educational opportunities and freedom
for the students uh but they would
absolutely be able to find the pathway
that works best for them so so just as a
followup to that so you're saying that
if I'm a parent and my kid is in one of
these categories that I can be assured
when I take that
EFA uh and apply it to the different
places that are taking efas that all of
them will accept me and my kid I'm not
going to speak for any of the individual
institutions but I feel as if those
parents within our educational system
system and with the the options that are
available to them that they are
empowered by efas we'll be able to find
the path that accepts them and works for
them okay just so yeah one more so my
point is that public schools have to
accept everybody so they're accepting
people who are lgbtq they're accepting
people that may be exposed to P fast or
whatever but not it seems to me not all
places that are accepting efas are are
accepting those people and I'm just
wondering how that so so okay we're
saying great parents you got all these
choices and then they go to exercise
those choices in fact we had this with
one other group and and the school the
organization or whatever it is the won't
accept them so how do you think you
should Rectify that well I I would say
that if the public school is so
accepting of these students and it's
still failing them and not serving their
needs and they feel unsafe or
unsuccessful in that school district
then it's really not Acceptance in the
public school just because they say
they're willing to accept those
categories uh and I believe the parents
would find those institutions and those
organizations that are willing to accept
their child and their student and put
them on the education pathway that works
best for them so I I I would I would
argue that a public school that may be
accepting on paper but is still failing
the student isn't accepting at
all
thank you are there other questions from
the
committee yes represent Bon thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question um I'm just looking at line
11b and it's very broad it says um that
who is concerned that attending school
could lead to the spread of contagious
diseases such as covid-19 the common
cold the seasonal flu pneumonia and
other similar diseases it it just says
that you have a
concern um it seems to me that it's a
very broad
category uh well we have experienced in
the past lockdowns due to diseases and
trying to control the spread of it um
the lockdown era is is gone and I hope
it never comes back but if a family or a
student is still worried about the the
potential to catch a disease and they
don't currently qualify for educational
Freedom accounts I think we should be
able to make them available to them it
may be it may be a broad category but
that's up to the individual family to
determine if they're worried about
getting sick or catching a a
transmittable disease at their
school thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question I mean to the same um
line item that specifically
describes um contagious diseases
including the common
cold does that include bed bugs and
lice that would be up to the family and
the parents and the student who is
applying for efas under this
hardship so if they are if they are a
family and they are worried about
getting lice or getting a common disease
as outlined in the bill they would be
able to qualify for educational Freedom
accounts under this
legislation just a quick followup but
they're not
diseases I'm I was just using your own
words in your question but if if they
are if they are worried about diseases
such as Co 19 the common cold the
seasonal flu pneumonia or other similar
diseases if they're worried about
catching that within the school system
they would be free to qual uh to apply
to qualify for educational Freedom
accounts under this
you thank you for taking my question
course so would it be correct to Simply
say that this bill Endeavors to provide
rationale by which any family could
qualify their student for an
EFA I mean if the family attests to one
of these categories they would qualify
under this bill but they would be
required to attest to one of the
categories in the bill follow yes so I'm
pretty sure no one actually wants one of
those contagious
diseases no one wants to be bullied I'm
not going to read off the whole
list it sounds like everyone qualifies
well it's it's not anybody who is afraid
of being bullied it's those students who
are persistently bullied which is
already defined in statute um as for the
diseases I I'm not aware of many
families who would be so concerned of
catching the diseases that they would
pull their students from public school
but I have seen remarks on Twitter uh
from some of our colleagues here in the
house worried about students going back
to school uh while diseases are running
rampant and so if those individual
families do fear uh the potential
catching and spread of diseases at
Public Schools I wanted to make sure
that they were qual they were eligible
for educational Freedom under this
bill I have an unrelated question me I
have a question that's a different line
may
I thank you Mr speaker thank you for
taking my question so in essence I'm
following representative bbon and
representative Damon This truly is um it
seems like anyway or I guess I should
ask you the universal eligibility
because if I don't qualify fin if I
don't qualif
financially I just and I really want to
get in this program I just say I'm I
don't want to get the flu I'm in so it
does seem like a
universal so so this this bill
establishes nine categories that a
parent has to attest to in order to get
their student qualified for educational
Freedom accounts so if they if they
qualify for one of these categories they
would what just one yep yeah so thank
you back to cor Damon did you I do and
thank you so relative to the category
line 22 regarding P pass
yep if the district drinking water
standards I would expect that it is
highly likely that almost everywhere
else in the community also exceeds the P
pass drinking water
standards so having the student change
where they get educated doesn't protect
them from that and there's nothing
stating
here that they need to go to an
educational setting where the P pass
standards are not exceeded but it would
give the family flexibility to send
their students outside of that zip code
outside of that area of contamination
and really just empower the family to
make the educational decision and the
lifestyle decision that works best for
them
follow thank you so when legislation
comes forward to address P passing
communities I hope we'll have your
support for addressing it ABS I've as a
member of the finance committee have
supported many efforts to clear our
communities of p and would absolutely
course are anys
represented represent
belg thank you Mr chair and thank you
gra s for bringing this so This
references Co and uh has a line about
the infectious diseases and whatnot now
um the New Hampshire Department of um
public health is still recommending for
children that they receive the covid-19
vaccine um now that's despite the fact
that I'm I'm not so sure that children
are are actually affected by covid-19
usually but one of the things
epidemiologists said was that they have
to receive the vaccine in order that
they don't spread it to older people who
are affected so along that same L of
thought would this then Empower uh
parents maybe one of them is autoimmune
comp or immune compromised to remove a
child if they're fearful that they might
catch something at school that could
come home and kill them absolutely thank
you very much for the question
representative Bel and that's really to
the point of the of why including that
provision in there if there is a family
at risk uh as you mentioned with
autoimmune disorder or what whatever
reason that they are fearful of catching
an infectious disease like covid or or
something similar uh this would be able
to to to protect that family um and make
it so that we won't see lethal
cases further question committee
repent thank you Mr Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question so would you
say that the co the one that are going
to use that one let's say the co that
they're not going to go to another
private school because there are a lot
of kids there too that they would likely
homeschool at that point I I certainly
don't want to speak for the family and
there may be educational pod
opportunities a ailable uh that would
provide a little bit more distancing or
different Health standards that might
align with the family's values um they
could potentially use it to to expand
homeschooling options or their ability
to homeschool or they can find a school
option that works for them so that I
wouldn't I wouldn't try to theorize what
the family would use it for thank
you I don't see any further
hands oh
hand thank you very much thank you very
all thank you Mr chair and seam members
of the House Education committee for the
record my name is Joe Alexander I
represent the town of
gtown so actually last Thanksgiving I
just celebrated my 10-year High School
reunion and I went to conquered high
school I'm still yes I'm 29y old baby so
um and I went to conquered high school
and I'm I'm kind of speaking from heart
here because most of you know that today
I identify as an
lgbtq individual I'm a 29-year-old man I
live with another man um I guess from my
experience and why I believe that this
bill is needed is because in high school
maybe I was not necessarily comfortable
enough coming out and being my authentic
self when I saw others in the schools
being bullied for being their authentic
self so in in that situation as somebody
who identifies as a member of this
community I think it's really important
that we provide students and families
options um even students that identify
as lgbtq so um I'm really just here to
to say that there's countless stories
like mine um we you know public schools
are great for most people but not
everyone and I think in a situation
where you identify in this way or you're
not really sure yet and you see others
that look like you or act like you being
bullied um you should have that
opportunity to use an education Freedom
account and go somewhere that has
a somewhere that better fits your needs
so with that I'm happy to take questions
thank you very much representative are
there questions for representative
Alexander yes representative cordelli
thank you uh thank you representative
alexand for being here um I'm just
looking for the difference between um I
don't know if you have the bill in front
of you uh e and i in that one it seems
like we're talking about the
25th bottom 25th percentile and the
other one we're talking about the bottom
10% 10 um 10th
percentile and I'm just wondering if you
know maybe one of those could be
eliminated well I'm I'm again you the
committee now has control over the bill
um I would say that if I'm looking
briefly at this geographical boundaries
of a school is different from um it the
state standardized testing so I mean if
you look at the gtown school district
it's goof toown and New Boston so that
would what I would interpret
geographical boundaries and then the
state scores are going to be different
from the Goof toown New Boston score so
that's how I would answer that perhaps
uh there might be an
answer thank you Mr chairman uh and
that's a great op observation
representative cordelli section e is for
the students who have tested in the
bottom 25th percentile and section I is
if the school district is in the bottom
10% okay so it's it's the student is is
UN if yeah student versus district and
that's why we're both named Joe so he
can help if we need
it any questions for representative Alex
yes representative Cornell thank you and
thank you for taking my question um it
says a resident of the state who is
eligible to enroll in a public
elementary or secondary school so I'm
assuming that these are students who are
in public schools now and want to leave
and get an EFA not students who are
already in a private parochial whatever
school
and want to start getting the EFA like a
student who identifies as lesbian
bisexual gay and they're in a private
school but they are eligible to enroll
can they get the money yes I mean that's
the way I read the definition of
Eligibility so they're already eligible
to receive that okay so but I'm talking
about my experience personally as a I
think you're a sponsor so I'm ask so I'm
I'm just wondering if if it's students
who are in a public school and they're
going to leave because of one of these
reasons or they're in a private school
and they have seen this and they say oh
that's me and then they ask for the EFA
even though they aren't
350% below property level will they
qualify to get this money I mean there
could be under this legislation there's
a number of reasons why students would
qualify so I would say in this situation
the way I mean that's the way I read
elig so they don't have to be in the
public
school I
mean I that's how I read the bill okay
questions not seeing any represent
Damon sorry Mr chair I was trying to
figure out how to frame this question
thank you for taking my question
representative
Alexander I'm wondering if you could
comment
about ways in which
any school environment public or
otherwise could be a safer more
appropriate place for folks on the
lgbtq identification or anyone else who
might be bullied yeah and and I hate to
speak for the entire Community because I
know others like to speak for me in the
community so I for that reason won't
really speak for the whole Community but
I will say from my own personal
experience that um seeing others bullied
made me uncomfortable being authentic in
my own skin and my own self so for that
reason I could see why this bill is
needed thank you very much are there
further questions not seeing any thank
you very much
Wilkey to the speaker
welcome
um good afternoon the red button or the
you know there you go it's red thank you
I'm Mary wilky and um I live in conquer
I'm a retired public school teacher and
I'm breaking a record I've never spoken
twice in the same day so this will be my
last though I promise um I'm here to
oppose HB 1561 and um I was interested
in hearing representative Sweeny I I
kind of related to a lot of what he was
saying because I also went to a very
good public school um that I think had
more resources than a lot of other
schools um and one thing he said and I
sorry he left because I'm trying to
quote him as accurately as I can I
believe he said that he had wonderful
experience there they helped him with
his speech disorder and all that uh and
then he I believe said but I recognize
that Salem as a property rich town is
not representative of all school
districts and that's kind of the point
that came up this morning that uh one
way you could deal with that is take out
a handful of kids from a property poor
District and give them what they need
and leave all the rest behind or you
could Elevate so that all the kids all
around the state have uh an equal
opportunity which is what clemont's
about um I also I I also had kind of
noticed the issue that um representative
Cornell raised and I think you know so
far uh something like 75% of the
students who have taken efas have
already been in private or home school
and so if so this as I read this statute
it means if there's um a student with an
eating disorder at St Paul's School
who's getting whose parents can afford
to pay uh for the
tuition she or he is going to get
another $5,000 from the state and I
don't understand the rationale for that
if they can get and I thought well maybe
the rationale is then they can if they
need some extra help with I therapy or
something maybe they could use the
$5,000 that I thought well then why not
just give th $1,000 to every child in a
public school who's who fits in who has
an eating disorder and let them get
therapy too I don't I don't understand
the rationale um you could
um let's see
um and I guess
uh the other thing that I guess a
broader point is and it's all connected
but if I do I really I felt that
certainly the sponsors seem very sincere
and they're concerned about students who
might have special issues or things that
make them feel more vulnerable whatever
it is but if you're concerned about
these categories of children and so
concerned that you're willing to push a
bill that has no cap in terms of budget
no no determined costs then what about
the students who won't be able to take
advantage of it because we all know
there are students who um might be
eligible but their parents can't afford
to make up the difference between the
tuition and and what the EFA pays for or
they parents can't provide the
transportation or maybe there's nothing
near there where they live so if you
have elevated levels of pfas in your
water at your school and you're saying
well give kids a chance to go somewhere
else great and then you're just going to
leave the other ones there drinking the
bad water it just seems inhumane to me
if you really think I don't mean you if
if the sponsors of the bill really feel
that these children are at risk then
what about the ones that are not going
to be able to take the EFA what's going
to happen to them and it seems to me
that well also I've noticed that there
are quite a few of private schools that
yes do not do refuse to take lgbtq
students they put it right on their
websites they refuse to take students
who have certain uh learning
disabilities um they certainly take
refuse to take students of a different
religion there are a lot of
opportunities that are not available to
um through this program to where the
where people are closed out of
um but it seems to me that in any
situation you're going to have some
students who need something extra or
have some extra vulnerability or
something and rather than identifying
these categories and who do we think are
at risk and give some of them money to
leave their public school but leaving
the rest of them behind and then sending
a lot of money to private school kids
who already are happy where they are
whether they're in one of these Cate or
not what if instead we had school a
school system where we just gave all the
students in these categories the
supports they need including clean water
and um what if we provided
transportation and what if we made them
open to everybody and free for everybody
and everyone could participate and they
all had an equal opportunity and that's
what our public school system is
supposed to be and I just would like to
see all of our efforts and all of our
extra money that seems to be lying
around going to the public schools we're
up to somewhere around 90% of our
students go thank you thank you very
much are there any questions
representative cordelli thank you uh
thank you for sticking around um uh just
a question on one thing you said about
are you aware of religious schools who
don't accept someone from that same
religion because I've I've had
conversations with people in the
Catholic schools community and um I've
heard about um the non-catholic schools
the great percentage of non-ath Catholic
students who attend those Catholic
schools and I was actually at a
conference a few years ago and um a girl
from Washington DC um her brother was in
jail her parents said we got to get you
out of this school because you're going
to end up the same way he did she went
to Catholic school she was not Catholic
um when she talked to us she was
studying for her PhD from Syracuse so
I'm just wonder if you have any examples
of that are you asking me if there are
some religious schools that won't take a
child from a different religion correct
yes there are some um I I could I don't
have the names in front of me I've seen
on websites some that say you have to go
to their particular Church to go not
even just be their religion um there's I
think a seventh day advocat well I don't
actually I don't want to say without
looking because I don't want to be
misrepresenting some there are quite a
few on their websites that do say you
have to be this religion and there are
others that don't others that say we
take people of all religions so it's a
mix I think
are there further questions yes
representative Bel beler and then
representative
leus thank you Mr chair and thank you
for the testimony um I'm going to try to
get this quite right but I probably
won't be perfect with it you you uh you
testified that you would like to us to
imagine a school um a public school that
was providing clean water um providing
all of the necessary things a student
needs to achieve where students are all
high Achievers and doing well and all of
the uh special ed children are taken
care of and all of their religions are
respected and imagine if we could just
do that
all can you provide an example of any
school in America that would fit those
criteria um I didn't say all those I
didn't say all those things um I didn't
mention religion for instance um I think
public schools are pretty careful to
stay out of religion because there's so
many religions and and non-religion um
well I don't know the the school that
representative Sweeny described seemed
like a school that met a special need in
a really great way and changed his life
no I don't think there's any school that
has worked for every single child but
that's why we have the Manifest um
hardship option but I do think um there
are I think often in this room I hear
Public Schools get characterized a lot
as sort of one size fits-all
I don't think they are I I I think they
make a real effort to meet all the needs
and no none of them is perfect I agree
but this bill doesn't say let's find a
school that's just not meeting a
specific need it's saying if you just
don't if you just
don't it's it's much more broad than
that it's much more vague than that and
um I think there are better ways I think
often when schools are not meeting
somebody's needs it's because they don't
have the resources to have that extra
special ed teacher or that extra
counselor but no I mean there's nothing
is perfect there's no perfect system in
the world and I'm sure I'm sure a lot of
either okay who did I say was next
represent
leus I'm trying to understand your point
in that you said um that you wanted to
see money go to all the students and yet
it was my bill you testified on earlier
where I was trying to get money to go to
all the students and you didn't want to
have that happen and
so can you explain I think I must have
misspoken or I wasn't clear I I didn't
say I want are you are you asking me if
that are you saying I'm now saying I
want um efas to go to all the students
not EFA money to go to support all the
students to have a good education which
is what I was trying to do with my bill
but now you're saying so I'm just trying
to understand what what it is that you
want with the what money to go to all
students the state money in the
education trust fund that I would like
to see go to all the public schools in a
more equal way so that a Salem doesn't
stand out as a place where somebody can
get that kind of therapy but recognizes
that his school isn't representative of
the schools around the state and
therefore he feels we need to take kids
out of those other schools and give them
other options so it's not all students
it's all public yes please it's not all
students it's all public schools that
you want the m to go to that correct on
behalf of those students thank you
further questions from the committee
representative Tanner thank you and
thank you for taking my question um in
your research did you find any schools
that wouldn't take lb lgbtq yes people
um I did I quite a few um one I just
have I wrote down a quote but I didn't
want to get I didn't have time to get to
it but um uh one's handbook says that we
have reserved the right to deny
admission to or expel a student for
quote professing to be a homosexual SL
bisexual transgender person or engaging
or practicing homosexual bisexual
transgender behaviors as well as
condoning supporting or otherwise
promoting such practices and that was
one of quite a few it was just a sample
could I have a followup on that yes so
um we've had a lot of discussion about
diversity inclusion and Equity um as
something that shouldn't be in public
schools do you feel as though that
diversion inclusion and Equity is
actually a way to make schools better
Public Schools better for people that
are lgbtq people who are bullied like
whatever the other categories are in
this particular thing probably doesn't
do much for p but
no I do and as a teacher
the I used to wonder why are people out
there saying such negative things about
public schools and diversity is and and
and about indoctrination I think are
they worried because we you know we take
everybody and so we have to say you
can't use certain words in a derogatory
way about certain classes of people or
categories of people and so we all have
to talk about those things because we
take everybody you know what are you
going to do the last class I taught I
had 24 students eight of them were from
um were refugees from Asia and Africa um
who were speaking English as a second
language and you know they were quote
different from the students that most of
my students had in earlier in their
lives bumped into we have to talk you
know so it's because we have are
welcoming everybody we want them to all
feel welcome and you can't do that if
you never address the issue of something
going on in the playground that's based
on those classes
thank you any further questions from the
committee thank you very much thank you
like to invite uh Matt
Southerton or you're just technical
support question okay if there's some
questions for technical support uh Matt
has not down put down a plus or a minus
on this bill so he's just here for
support or offering
support a technical question yes you may
so I have a number of questions for you
um can you tell me what percentage of
EFA students have been turned
down um admission to a school that they
applied for or applied to applied to uh
like if you got an EFA and you wanted to
use your money for a particular school
and they turned you down can you tell me
what percentage of students that's
happened to I'm not a of any that that's
happened to okay are you talking Charter
Schools or public schools or I'm talking
anybody who has he's representing
Charter Schools well I'm I'm
representing CSF yeah yeah okay okay
okay yeah I wasn't here
this oh I I'm sorry Matt suton
fund so I I would say I'm not aware of
any schools that have turned down any
student for for being
lgbtq in fact I I literally just helped
a young lady that was 13 years old about
a month ago uh fill out the application
to a to a local Catholic school for her
and her brother who is on an IEP so I'm
not aware of any schools that have
turned anyone down okay thank you and
another question yes another question
thank you
[Music]
um are you aware of any students who
have had who have not been able to find
a place that fits them you know a place
I'm asking you because you have the
children's scholarship money and
whatever so um are you aware of any who
were not then able to find a place that
fits them uh no I mean honestly I think
that this program has helped a lot of
people I know that I work for CSF and
you'll probably think that I have a bias
um I I think that these this this
program has helped a lot of students
anecdotally I just helped a student that
was 6 years old 7 years old this this
weekend her her her mom contacted us
because her initial order was rejected
because we thought that it was a
household item it was for a little it
was for a little um mixer a handheld
mixer we thought it was a household item
and it turns out that this young girl
was blind and deaf and in her IEP it
called for she needed items that were
manipulative so that she could learn
through touch and through scent and so
that I adjudicated that order I spoke
with the mom this weekend and we got
that straightened out and she was able
to reorder her items and then I approved
that order okay so thank you very much
are there any other questions yes
representative Miler thank you for being
here Mr SEL what's the average um EFA
Grant the average EFA award I believe
it's around $5,300 currently okay thank
you thank you further
questions thank you very much thank you
house okay good afternoon Deborah H
president of the American Federation of
teachers New Hampshire and I'm here to
speak opposition to HP
1561 which would expand the state uh
voucher program to different categories
of student uh let me be clear on behalf
of our 3700 members who mostly work in
PRK through 12 Public Schools across the
state we find that this would be um an
inappropriate use of State funds in a
way that does not benefit our granted
State
students uh Grand State students have so
many needs right now stability academic
challenges support to meet their
learning needs and state welcoming
schools where every student belongs
learn they do not want a expanded
voucher program that seems to be aimed
at dividing our communities dividing
some parents from our public
schools and uh much of what I was going
to say has already been brought up in
the questioning so I'm skipping around a
little bit here but they want kids to
get a well rounded education develop
strong fundamental academic skills and
have Pathways to Career College and
Beyond that's what our families tell us
that's what they have shown Us in local
and Municipal elections and school
boards people who have run on strong
support for public schools have won in
the past year in our Municipal elections
they tell us this all the time that they
want to see their Public Schools
supported and they want to see it
supported just as robustly in Claremont
Franklin and Berlin as they are in
Bedford Handover and Windom they want
the opportunity for that public school
education to be just as real and just as
well resourced with the small class
sizes the academic support the social
emotional support that you get in your
bedfords and Windom as you that you can
get in Claremont and
Berlin and
having money go into any voucher program
and expanding it like
this makes it harder for the state to
fulfill its duty to its granted State St
to all students in the graned state
because you do have a constitutional
duty to each and every one of those
Grant State students to provide that
public education that is just as robust
in every single District across the
state and hits property taxpayers just
as like lightly or just as hard in every
single
District uh it was brought up that this
Voucher Program could allow
vouchers for students who are lgbtq or
family members who are but that there
may
be um education service providers who do
not accept such students and um we heard
another speaker address that that that
is indeed the case going by their
handbooks I have some um citations on
that and I will hand it in my
testimony
um also an average
$5,300 a year for a voucher is not going
to get you into the promise that
vouchers have that he going to get you
you know help you with elite private
schooling like Philip texer or St Paul's
it's not going to come close to paying
tuition for uh an elite private
school the experience with most voucher
programs across the country is that it
actually harms
academic achievement it has a worse
impact on academic achievement than
Hurricane krina Katrina or covid-19
disruptions and I have citations of that
as well and I will be emailing this
because it's in links
um expanding the school voucher program
will help any child who needs our
support it will
only make it harder for the state to
meet its constitutional obligation to
all students which is to provide that
robust public education
system and let's be honest who benefits
most from this bill it's not Granite
State
students it's transparently a tax
subsidy for families who are already
choos choosing to send their students to
private school or to homeschool
them most of these students who are
using
vouchers were not in public school when
the program started and those uh joining
the program have not been in public
school they have not been leaving public
school for this it's an education
welfare program for those who can afford
other options and it does nothing to
help us meet our constitutional
obligation to gr State students so I
urge you to vote no on HB 1561 our kids
deserve better than this they deserve a
robust well-rounded opportunity for a
public education in every single
District in the state and our property
tax payer payers deserve to be footing
the bill at an equal rate across the
state not heavier in one District than
in another District so we can all
benefit like the
original um maker of the bill was
talking about he benefited from his
public schools and with that thank you
are you willing to take questions I will
take them I if I don't have the facts to
answer them I will um get back to you
because I do not want to answer
unfactual represent dry y thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking the
question sorry you don't match your name
tag that threw me off for a moment
and
thank you you continuously refer to the
program as a voucher program the voucher
program was repealed in
1988 so there's no statutory definition
of a voucher
program is there a question that wasn't
a question is there do in the you prer
another term I would for a language
point of view statutory Le defined thing
that you could
use so it's not a Bach program
voucher system voucher scheme sounds
judgmental so follow would you consider
educational Freedom accounts which is
what the bill is about well it's a
voucher though so I do yeah something
are there other questions represent
cordelli uh thank you thank you for
being here um a lot of the uh uh
concerns you raised about this bill
related to funding and funding of public
schools um but how about the actual CR
criteria in this bill for eligibility
for students um for instance a
persistent bullied student I don't think
has anything to do with uh funding for a
school in particular so wouldn't that be
um a valid option uh for a child who is
being persistently bullied and uh uh not
having a remedy in the local school to
uh possibly get an education Freedom
account that there are two uh parts to
my response one is um there is already
the Manifest hardship route that a
family can take and certainly there are
cases where a student is being bullied
and you know the option should be
considered working through the
counseling working through the chain of
command and the principal and Reporting
um all issues as always should be done
when there are instances like that
another part to that response though is
is there enough staff on hand is there
enough supervision on hand are are there
the right number of behavior specialist
counselors to deal with the student
population in that school so there could
be uh evidence of a systemic problem
especially if there's more than just one
isolated incident of incident of
bullying so you could be talking about a
funding issue that you do not
have uh an appropriate Staffing level in
the school to to take care of all the
students needs in that school yes um and
you're right there there are options
because uh a student now who is
persistently bullied and that in that um
situation is being neglected by the
school uh can actually sue the school
district so that is another option for
that student um you're correct in that
regard um but you also mentioned U
manifest education hardship um how about
a student who is granted manifest
education hardship as in um I or excuse
me J um but goes to their neighboring
public school and is denied admission or
the other public school neighboring that
district and it's denied
addition admission into that public
school and um this child happens to be
special needs shouldn't that child have
another
option
I I think that was a question you think
you're yeah I would have to look at the
statute to see if there is already an
Avenue for uh appealing denials so that
you can find a correct fit this seems
like an awfully extreme option to create
um what's essentially Universal voucher
system with what's going to be an $83
million in new spending in FY 2025 alone
that's new spending on top of the
existing spending in the voucher system
um if we don't like
program yes are there further questions
represent
leus yes the amount in addition that you
just mentioned how did you come up with
that
amount uh that was an analysis
I believe bring higher New Hampshire did
on I would have to look at their put
notes to tell you exactly how they
derive that but they did the math thank
you you're welcome so just as a point of
clarification then uh because I was
going to ask about the fiscal notes we
have 49 bills with fiscal notes of which
we haven't received over half of them
the fiscal notes yep so your data does
not come from the
LBA no no my data not come from the lb
committee thank you very much okay like
Hawkins uh good afternoon Mr chair
chairman members of the committee for
the record Brian Hawkins today
representing Nea New Hampshire I will
try not to repeat a lot of what has
already been said today um we're here in
opposition to uh HP
1561 um we feel that this legislation
would result in a dramatic expansion of
the school Voucher Program something
that the legislature rejected last year
because of the potential Financial
consequences it could have with our
ability to support uh
a universal public education for New
Hampshire students um specifically this
bill and to certain extent the previous
Bill did this by lifting the income cap
on certain categories of students and
when uh HB 464 from last year was
rejected um that was uh done so um in
Senate education in the Senate education
committee with the concern that it would
um uh potentially blow a hole completely
into the uh education trust fund um so
with this bill the extraordinarily Broad
and somewhat vague categories of
students between these uh this bill and
the last bill create what amounts to a
universal uh eligibility to the school
voucher program and as uh president
Tuttle mentioned earlier this morning um
we've seen what that has resulted in in
States like Arizona where they're now
facing a budget deficit uh uh in large
part due to that uh program being 1400%
over uh the budgeted amount for that um
for that amount we you know we're we
have a subcommittee now obviously some
of you are on it um to try and get to a
point where we're not
50th in the nation in terms of the state
support for uh its share of uh public
education um um the uh no income limit
on various
categories um is also concerned because
there's no additional accountability
measures
um the uh legislature has also just
begun work uh you mentioned legislative
budget assistant on a performance audit
for the program that only began I think
days or weeks ago um and so we feel be
premature to expand the program before
that uh audit is
complete
um we uh we mentioned uh some of the uh
the categories earlier outlined into the
bill I would just add uh additional
concern here is that um you're not
adding any Protections in the EFA law
for the students that are in some of
these categories
that it's purporting to help and so
there are no anti-discrimination
protections in uh in the law in the EFA
law uh nor does it
extend uh protections like there are in
the uh State bullying law to private
schools uh it was mentioned admission
was mentioned earlier too
um and the program shifts a lot of key
expenses to parents who then of and have
to subsidize private tuition for
families who would never have enrolled
in a public school uh I'll conclude by
just saying that you know we finished a
uh teacher shortage committee um this
past year where we talked about the need
to do things like reduce class sizes
raise
pay uh so that we can address the
shortages that are in our schools not
only with teachers but with support
staff as well um and rather than divert
money to this
program uh which as far as we can tell
is an unknown amount because of these
very broad some of these very broad
categories we should address that uh
Workforce issue uh first um so thank you
for your uh time and I'm happy to answer
any questions thank you very much Mr
Hawkins are there any questions yes
represent pel thank you Mr chair and
thank you for being here and taking my
question this is a question relating
classroom size so if students left the
classroom in pursuit of an education
Freedom account um opportunity would
that reduce the classroom
size well uh depending on how many uh
students left um because of the funding
model that we use in the state um the
students who uh are going to remain um
there the community would um shoulder an
even larger burden to help
maintain the personnel and the uh
building itself so I don't I don't see
how um you know uh kid kids leaving the
public school is going to help with
um encouraging class size it probably
will encourage consolidation of anything
into larger classes so that would be a
concern further questions
thank you very much appreciate your time
B good afternoon um Mr chairman
and thank you so I just like to First
say that I'm in support of this bill I
am actually a receiver of the EFA I was
uh homeschooled and um up until last
year and now I'm in an awesome small
private school in candy New Hampshire
and they have fulfilled many of my needs
that I would have struggled with I have
one of them is math I'm a little behind
in math and last year was even more
behind and since they're smaller they
actually allowed me to have a private
tutor and I did three years of math in
four semesters and now I'm caught up and
I'm only a year behind and then next
year I'll be doing regular grades with
math with my class um the public schools
they you know they fulfill a lot of
needs for a lot of other children but
the problem is once it gets to such a
certain size some of my own personal
friends I have never been to public
school but I have friends that went it
just they don't always meet all the
certain needs of every single
individual and so the what the EFA
allows is for that individual to to be
able to take the money that they would
still receive through the state if
they're in public school and allow them
to go to a better place maybe that fits
their needs better you know um cuz
School especially teenagers middle
schoolers and young kids they spend the
majority of their four years you know
maybe of that lifetime there and it can
really affect a difference this small
school I went to they've had kids two of
them are from Nigeria um
and they picked this school because
they're able to help fulfill their needs
you know maybe a little behind in
English and others like that we also
have two Chinese students and they're
able to fulfill their needs because
they're smaller so I think that this is
a really good bill because it allows
each individual to pick and choose what
is best for them because the public
school can't meet everyone thank you
thank you very much Alisha any questions
yes representative miler
thank you Mr chair an Alicia thank you
for being here and I'm glad you're back
on track um what school did you
ultimately decide to go to uh Jesse
Remington High School which one Jesse
Remington High School in Candia New
Hampshire thank
you represent
P thank you Mr chairman thank you for
being here where did you learn your
public speaking skills
pack cordelli
yes thank you so much for being here and
your wonderful testimony I
just I wouldn't normally ask but could I
ask your age um 17 great follow up yes
um from your description of your class
um I'm not sure their opinions on things
but it seems like quite a diverse
classroom you're in it how many how many
students are in the classroom um so even
though it's smaller school I only have
um 11 kids in my class but I have one
boy from Nigeria uh one girl from China
who was able to come here is a very
diverse class so even though it's
smaller it all fits our needs better and
we we we're all closer honestly like as
a group thank you any further questions
of Alicia yes representa Tanner thank
you for coming and you're doing a great
job I I was having difficulty hearing
though which is my issue um did you say
that you had not attended any public
high school no no but I have a lot of
friends who uh went from public school
to Jesse Remington and maybe a few of
them bullying problems or just that the
teacher was not able um to fit their
specific needs one of um the girls had
she's a very nice girl and a really good
friend of mine but she had a lot of
problems with anxiety so even though she
was a high overachiever and she was
always getting good grades the you know
because of the larger class size the
school was overlooking that so when she
came to our school it came like very
relevant if she didn't get like a 98 or
something she would have like a mini
panic attack seriously and unfortunately
that led to a um some serious mental
health stuff for her but uh the school
the past year they've still been helping
her with school work the teacher talked
her each week and I'm glad to say she's
going to return with us tomorrow good
thank you so much any further questions
well thank you very much I applaud you
on your your ability to communicate what
you wanted to do today and I you did an
excellent job and on behalf of the whole
you last speaker Kate
Shay thank you Mr chairman thank you
committee Kate Shay from gtown seen many
of you in the past good to be here again
there's a quote that I really like which
says when the human in me sees the human
in you we make progress and I wanted to
start out with that because I'm very
much human today coming up a very
difficult year of losing my father and
my mother and just being sick myself so
please forgive me as I try to read these
words that are way too small for my old
eyes um I'm here to support all of these
EFA bills today um just very
briefly I'm the standing Survivor of
some Devastation to my family personally
and have seen it in my own town back in
2020 I'm going to go off the rails here
a little bit we had groups of people
coming into the school board and arguing
over masks or no masks and it was this
huge division right does everybody
remember that and I went in with some
information from the doe some new
programs coming out and they said I
don't think we have to make a decision
of us against them I think we can come
up with something that fits both sides
and our district on unfortunately did
not want to take part in that but I'm
happy to say that those homeschool they
guess they're considered homeschool
because you have to declare that status
but those pods have grown and grown and
they're meeting a diverse need of
students and you just heard from the
last student I wanted to share with you
a quote from Mike mcshain of Forbes
Magazine here's to the kids in the
banana costumes which Fe featured a
progressive and real discussion of the
challenges in education helping kids
find Solutions I can think of few better
metaphors he says visual metaphors for
micro schools and other Alternative
Learning environments than a happy child
in a banana
costume I'll have you know that was my
child in the banana costume who has
autism I'll be happy to forward you that
article he was one of two uh um post um
publicists that put out an article about
this being the way of the future and
that we cannot continue to try to solve
the same problems the same way
so for many per perfectly reasonable uh
reasons traditional schools can't
accommodate someone who wants to wear a
banana costume right I mean that's not
something you can go to work in your
banana costume um but there are students
who need to have a more orderly
distraction free learning environment um
there are some in the banana suit or not
who don't neatly fit in the box and one
flavor we've allowed those with most
potential and most vulnerable isn't
working I'll also note that these are
not kids who take any standardized tests
well nor do these tests provide any
tangible help to them directly in their
educational
Journey there are many reasons why these
kids need other options from the article
Logan's twin sister was bullied in her
old school and said as well of her new
environment it's calmer here no one is
making fun of me as Mike McShan said in
the article if that doesn't break your
heart I don't know what to tell
you if you do the math the options are
not a takeaway I've testified many times
s before about inefficiencies caused by
federal Ida law which leads to more
expensive customers of our Public School
System including in my own town where we
have many outof district placements
these are some of the most expensive
placements that we have and there are
options available as I mentioned going
to my town and saying hey you know you
have these other options you can route
these students this other
direction so just as you wouldn't
continue to do something inefficient in
your household it doesn't make sense to
it here either no amount of Band-Aids or
IEP documents will fix a simple
situation that can be addressed by
saying if the plant does not flower
don't fix it change its
environment and I can tell you that the
children who have through the pandemic
challenges found their way to these
alternative paths are thriving and they
are not Republican children they are not
Democrat children they are our children
in New Hampshire all of our children
this creates opportunity and you heard
from the gentleman earlier it wouldn't
do much for that but I I beg to differ
that it creates space to fairly address
the mainstream children who are
expanding past the brick building faster
than we can address it's the right thing
to do and Innovation generally creates
positive
outcomes the opposite of that holds back
children holds back families who
experienced socioeconomic race gender
and all kinds of bias I mean these are
our students who need gender affirmation
I'm speaking directly in terms of
children that I know that are part of
our school and these are students that
could not remain in the mainstream
because they were not in a gender
affirming
environment it seeks to hold them down I
don't think this committee is about that
again going back to when the human in
you sees the human in me with my shaky
voice and all we can make progress I
know we can I know we've done it in the
past so let's do the right thing New
Hampshire let's move these EFA bills
forward and stop putting limitations
where not needed thank you thank you are
there any questions from the committee
yes represent cordelli thank you uh
thank you michay for being here welcome
back um as I recall in the past you've
testified on a number of special
education bills I I think maybe one or
two of your children have had
IEPs um are where are they um thank you
um uh where are they these days are they
in one of the pods that you mentioned
they are thank you for that so two of
mine went to a VX route they needed the
pressure off in the environment and they
are excelling and for all those that
knock VX it's an amazing program of many
times former public school teachers and
some of them actually are existing
Public School teachers so they are
thriving they're actually preparing as
14-y olds to consider what their careers
are going to be and what college path
they're going to follow and they have
regular inter interactions with teachers
they have to have the collaborations
with other students there's even a
homeschool kickball group that we joined
this year that has all ages and you know
what all these kids that never got the
chance to play kickball they're out
there playing kickball and the younger
two are part of a pipod which has grown
exponentially and they've done
exceptionally well and went from a
10-year-old not reading to reading off
the charts to making a friend with
someone in India that I have to tell
them okay you can't be talking to your
friend in India in the middle of the
night um it's opened all kinds of doors
that I wouldn't have imagined uh and and
I will tell you I was probably having
been the child of a public school
teacher and I have two sisters there
public school teachers probably a a
pretty strong critic of what I thought
alternative schooling was it flipped
everything upside down for our family
and we are no longer struggling six
years of family court was it wasn't
needed we didn't need that if we could
have found a path sooner we didn't have
to struggle into Che your point we had
IEPs that were about this thick High and
the inefficiency that that caused the
school district and the teachers I would
look them in the eye and there would be
10 of them and one of me and they would
want to tell me that this was just
miserable and we can see that through
the droves that have left so long story
short they're
thriving you know there're are teachers
who are finding their ways to other
options if they don't like the
mainstream option they can find an
option too so this isn't just for k it's
it's for everybody so thank you thank
you thank you very much are there
further questions from the committee not
seeing any thank you very much thanks so
much and with that we're going to close
1561 and we'll move to the last bill of
the day which is
you 1665 is an act relative to student
eligibility for the education Freedom
accounts
program go ahead welcome representative
pelli uh thank you very much Mr chairman
and committee members um for the record
Glenn cordelli representing uh tuffen
Boro wolfboro and oapi in the beautiful
Lakes Region and uh I'm here uh to talk
about House Bill
1665 uh an expansion of the education
Voucher Program oh excuse me I mean the
education Freedom accounts program um
but basically this uh increases the
income eligibility cap from 30 50% to U
500% and um it struck me uh yesterday
during testimony on one of the um one of
the um food
meals um
bills where I think it was uh the lady
um income does not take expenses into
account when they were looking to
increase the cap on their program and I
agree completely I was uh I've been on
the phone recently a number of times
with a mom from um
Swansea whose husband works for the
state of New York and commutes to uh
Albany um three days a week uh he makes
a very good salary about
$150,000 but she was telling me you
can't believe the expenses the expenses
of the travel over to Aly um all the
other expenses they have related to that
but he wants to stay in his job there uh
for his retirement
system and I can
um imagine why he wants to do that um
but the 500% income
cap according to n excuse me
2022 uh
federal poverty guidelines a family of
two at
500% would be an income of
$91,500
let me point
out
2022 New Hampshire family median income
$87,200 federal poverty guidelines for a
family of four
$38,750
median
income
135,136
per.
and median
if you put them all on a ranking medium
is the mid midpoint so we're at the
midpoint of family income with this
increase to
500%
so there's a many below and we're
dealing with the lower income uh
families still because they're below the
median or right at the median income for
a family of their size
so um that is why I chose the
500% uh level um as uh I thought a
reasonable and valid uh family income
cap um with all due respect to
representative lak's bill um but uh that
was my reasoning for choosing the 500%
level and I think the committee thank
you very much are you willing to take
questions sure are there any questions
from the committee yes representa Miler
yes uh thank you for your data could you
repeat the data again please sure I can
provide copies as well but um federal
poverty guidelines for
2022 um for a family of two at 500% it
is
$91,500
$87,200 would you like the family of
four also please sure uh family of four
500% is
$38,750
and the median income
$135
833 follow up yes go ahead so then what
would be the 500% what were your figures
there that that is the 500 that was 500%
100% further questions representor
Tanner thank you um do you have any idea
why the legislative budget office can't
come up with fiscal notes on something
like this um where you have the the the
definitely above my pay grade level but
you have the
statistics um yeah I I didn't get these
statistics from them um uh I I know that
they're busy working on a number of
projects I know uh I think they're right
now working on a special education uh
performance audit also uh so I'm I'm not
sure um the the timing and the a number
of uh projects they're working
leus those who are at that median level
do they qualify for other scholarships
do you know that would help them to
afford
a private or other school to for their
children um well they would not qualify
for the tax credit scholarship program
uh but there are many private schools
Catholic schools um non-religious
private schools that offer scholarships
to students a great many um EFA students
who go to private schools um get a
scholarship um from that that school um
um I believe I read a year or two ago
that the um average cost in a for a
Catholic elementary school was something
in the $8,000 price range um for tuition
and um again you could get a scholarship
on top of the EFA even for those who are
at the middle at the mid-range the
500% uh I haven't asked anyone in a
private school about the 500% level but
uh um yeah okay thank you further
questions from the committee yes
representative Pell thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question did
you just say that the tuition at a
Catholic school was $8,000 and correct
me if I'm wrong but our it cost about
$20,000 to educate a student um publicly
in new I I believe a couple of years ago
that was the number that was quoted to
me for a Catholic Elementary
School further
questions
not see thank you very much oh
representa D thank you I'm actually not
sure whether this question is for
representative cordelli or you chair lad
or both but appr propo of the lack of
fiscal note the statement attached to
the bill says that the LBA can't do it
because they don't have the data they
need from doe so can we exert some
leverage on
doe and not just on this fiscal note
well I think that they're probably doing
fiscal notes for criminal justice for
education for transportation you know
not doe but all these folks but they all
go through LBA but LBA has to get the
data first I I know it and when we're
talking about 49 bills that we have
alone they're trying to carve them out
and actually I I feel that we've gotten
some fiscal notes this year that we
hadn't gotten any in the previous year
so I I would say they're a little bit
ahead of the game I know that uh Mark
and Caitlyn and Company are trying to do
that and they know we're looking for
this stuff unfortunately our date to get
some of this out is in a couple weeks
February
15 further further questions of
Representative cordelli yes
representative Hall I have a question
thank you for um Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question does it I'm
curious does it matter to you what
school note would say or is it more does
it matter how high or low or whatever in
your in terms of no I'm I'm I'm trying
to do what I think is right with this
bill so it doesn't matter the cost thank
you further questions i' representa
cordelli yes representative Bon uh thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question along uh representative Hall's
questioning um last year we looked at
the bill and we Rose we just just raised
it up to 350 and now we're looking at
500 and you say that you just want to do
what's right what's are we going to be
year are you suggesting legislation for
next year
already no I'm just questioning the tent
end perhaps that would be a question for
okay um any further questions from the
committee thank you very much one last
card that I
have you weren't here for the initial
thing I said were you uh Mr Christina uh
thank you very much chairman L know I
wasn't but the the pink cards that come
in that have manuscript or
cursive with some doubt as far as how to
read that individual will stay after
school tonight the curs of law is just
being implemented if I'm not mistaken
from a year or two ago
oh welcome Barrett thank you uh thank
you chairman L good afternoon um members
of the committee um I wasn't going to
testify but representative pel you seem
very surprised that the cost of a
Catholic Elementary School is $88,000
per year well the cost of a public
school education is about $20,000 per
year um I presume you also know why that
may be but in case anybody on the
committee is confused um Catholic
schools are not providing special
education services to the extent that
public schools are doing them when a
child needs an out of District placement
it is not the church that's paying for
that it's the public schools um likewise
um uh as members of the committee may
know um uh the state of New Hampshire um
has routinely cut all funding from the
uh from the New Hampshire retirement
system they used to pay a portion of the
fees that locals had to pay to the
retirement system they cut that back in
2013 if we want to run through the
expenses the public schools are
obligated to meet versus the the the
expenses that private schools choose to
meet um our public schools and our
school boards all happy to do that we'll
do that any day of the week if there are
any questions relative to that point or
the bill in general or vouchers I'm
happy to answer
them are there questions of the new
Schoolboard Association represent leas
could you get us that information I
would appreciate it thank you very I
don't know if I can get that for for
private schools but I can certainly get
a listing of all the obligations that
public schools are required to to
compile have you gotten the law books
yet from from the Department of
Education if you have the ABD the
annotated one or the or the the the thin
one it's somewhat annotated there you go
I mean those are the mandates those are
all the mandates of the things that we
have to do representative and my
annotated version I think they maybe
Abridged the annotated version is
representative cordelli and lad and
probably Miley you know some of those
have been 15,600 pages is right so but I
I mean I can I mean I guess the other
thing to do would be to you know talk to
your business manager go through your
local District budget and see if they
can differentiate mandated costs versus
sort of arbitrary costs or costs that
that they choose to do that the voters
are are opting to to pay for okay thank
you because these don't give no no no
they're just the law right they're just
the laws right so having the costs would
be very see what I can do than I
certainly we have a working list of all
the unfunded mandates that the
legislature is passing about that would
be awesome or so Becky so I would love
to see that we'll send that to the
committee as well too thank you yep
further questions uh from the represent
Tanner um do private schools and
religious schools have to abide by Ada
like uh put in um elevators or you know
special thank you for the question ref
I'll be honest with you I don't know
what private schools are obligated to do
or or federal laws that they're required
to apply I that's something don't know
the answer to that I I think under some
of the municipal codes fire right that
code health safety and at my
understanding too that if there are I
mean I don't want to get myself in
trouble here if it's a quote unquote
historic building or if there are
significant upgrades or renovations to
them they have to come into compliance
with some sort of updated building codes
but offhand Ada and whatnot I don't I
mean you're shaking your out I believe
you're represent I just don't the answer
of that fur further questions from the
committee thank you very much thank you
you're welcome Mr chair yes can I ask a
technical question Mr s regarding sure
if he's willing not of you Barrett oh
I'm sorry sure Matt
Souther are you willing to answer a
technical
question thank thank you for asking this
I I've had this query in my own mind
a couple of years ago for example I
looked at the conquered Christian
Academy and what it cost to go there
okay and I believe and this was like
maybe three years ago and I believe it
was about 135 so okay it's probably now
let's say 155 okay and a student who
gets an EFA voucher for
$5,300 what happens to the other 10
that's a that's an excellent question I
actually was not familiar with private
schools prior to taking this position
myself so this is a great learning
experience for me too um students that
need financial aid to attend these
programs are given financial aid
packages and essentially what happens is
the the more affluent families subsidize
those
students so they would those the the
more affluent families would pay the
full tuition ride and then a student
that needs the financial aid package
that would they would just basically
basically they would do away with it
right they would say we're going to give
you $10,000 in uh you know financial aid
and then we'll use the EFA for the 5,000
okay thank you very much and that's just
that's just an example yeah yes um thank
you for taking my question have you seen
tuitions Rising lately in the private
sector I I couldn't answer that with any
specificity I I wouldn't know okay I
just thought well I think the answer to
that is yes
it's it's definitely occurring in fact I
can tell you the one that my grandkids
go to it's public SL
private and the tuition for a boarding
student now is up close to $70,000 a
year and the tuition is at
$22,000 and the Catholic School within
that particular Community is up around
16,000 it's climbing everywhere due to
the cost of doing
so any further
questions thank you again thank you
thank do we have any other cards for
this particular bill this is
1665 not seeing we're going to close
this
hearing and that takes us to the end of
the agenda for today appreciate
everybody coming today and testifying
and the next meeting of this body will
be tomorrow
we get out early today yeah there we
yeah we're getting out early today and
no
snow